Herzlich willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge Nr. 20.
Über den politischen Diskurs diesmal und wir sind sehr stolz, heute einen besonderen Gast zu haben, nämlich Herrn Schirrmacher von der FAZ.
Hallo.
Guten Tag.
Ja, der politische Diskurs ist ja etwas, was Ihnen ja schon sehr lange am Herzen liegt und der verfall dasselbe und deswegen wollten wir da heute mal ein bisschen darüber reden und auch mal ein bisschen Ausblick darauf nehmen, wie sich die Sache dann in Zukunft gestalten wird mit dem Internet und der Beschleunigung, die durch das Internet passiert und den ganzen Effekten, die wir jetzt so in der letzten Zeit beobachten können. Wir haben jetzt ja gerade so einen schönen Fall, nämlich halt irgendwie diesen Staatstreu anhand dessen, man ja doch irgendwie auch den Zustand des politischen Systems Bundesrepublik ganz hervorragend betrachten konnte.
Und die Piratenpartei, das ist beides so Gelegenheiten.
Genau, die Piratenpartei, da dachten wir, das wäre doch eigentlich mal die Gelegenheit, es doch mal zu debattieren.
Wir fangen aber im historischen Überblick an.
Wie immer, genau.
Und wenn man politischer Diskurs sagt, meint man eigentlich so die legendären Bundestagsreden und Einrufe von Wehner und Willy Brandt und Schmidt. Und wir empfehlen sehr, sich da mal durch YouTube zu klicken. Wir werden ein paar Videos verlinken. Und wenn man sich diese Videos ansieht, dann kann man auf der einen Seite feststellen, dass sich der Duktus geändert hat. Die Leute haben früher mit mir Gravitas geredet, haben sich mehr Zeit gelassen für ihre Sätze und haben eine andere Betonung gehabt. Aber man sieht auch meines Erachtens ganz gut, dass es einen anderen Respekt gab vor Politikern als heute. Also wenn jemand wie der Willy Brandt eine Rede gehalten hat, da gab es dann zwar auch Zwischenrufe. Aber wenn die Presse den interviewt hat, dann haben die schon so eine Stufe tiefer gestanden. Während heute gibt es ja auch so einen Krawall-Journalismus, wo die dann regelrecht ablauen.
Wobei Willy Brandt gerade so ein Fall ist, auch gerade hier in Berlin, der wurde schon ganz schön auseinandergenommen. Also ich glaube, der Respekt, den sehen wir jetzt in der Rückschau. Also wir sehen jetzt das, was die Leute damals für selbstverständlich hielten, dass neben dieser Tagespolitik dort eine Empathie war oder eine Überzeugung von der Sache, die man heute eher mit der Lupe suchen muss. Da ist Willy Brandt natürlich das Beispiel. Aber Willy Brandt wurde sowas von fertig gemacht. Da wurde, ich weiß noch, eine Panoramasendung, die ich als Schüler sah, wo es um Willy Brandt ging. Und danach konnten die Zuschauer diskutieren, also schon vor Internetseiten. Weiß ich noch, wie einer anrief und sagte, dieser Mann gehört füsiliert, noch heute an die Wand gestellt, er hat die Deutschen verraten.
Wegen Ostverträgen?
Nein, nein, weil er im Zweiten Weltkrieg in Schweden gewesen ist. So war das damals. Das kann man sich heute gar nicht mehr vorstellen. Der galt als Vaterlandsverräter, weil er auf der anderen Seite gewesen ist. Also das ändert nichts daran, dass sich die Qualität geändert hat, aber ich glaube, die Bösartigkeit war damals genauso, wie sie heute ist.
Also ihr meint, der Respekt, den reden wir uns nur im Nachhinein ein.
Ja, es gab, ich würde mal so sagen, es gab also von den Medien sowieso nicht, gab es einen legendären Spiegeltitel, Willy Brandt, das Denkmal bröckelt. Das war, wissen wir heute noch, das war nach seinem Friedensnobelpreis, das ihn das völlig fertig machte auch, dieser Titel. Aber es gab etwas anderes, das war, so banal das klingt, die, glaube ich, mehr oder minder doch, mit ein paar Ausnahmen, eine generation, und damit haben wir heute jetzt zu tun, die wusste, also für die war die Bundesrepublik, nehmen sie mal jetzt das Jahr 1970, da war das Ende des Zweiten Weltkrieges noch nicht so lange her, also 25 Jahre. Das ist jetzt wie 1984, oder? So nah war das da. Also die haben sozusagen noch, diese generation hat das, was war, nie als was Normatives gesehen, sondern als eine Anomalie, so glaube ich. Also darum Herbert Wehner. Ich empfehle jedem, es gibt ein Herbert Wehner YouTube-Video, das ich unglaublich finde. Da wird eher etwas gefragt, was wir heute schon gar nicht mehr verstehen, nach Wahlen, wie er das sieht. Die SPD hat schlecht abgeschnitten. Und dann wird er von dem provozierenden Interviewer gefragt, ist das doch schlecht für sie und so weiter. Und darauf sagt er, das und das ist passiert und das ist gut für die Demokratie. Da merkt man bei dieser generation, dass sie noch immer das Gefühl haben, das Eis, auf dem wir uns bewegen, ist sehr dünn. Und die wenigstens demokratischen Parteien sind stark und nicht die anderen. Das sind solche Dinge, die, glaube ich, damals fast in der DNA waren. Und heute natürlich ist viel länger, viel mehr Zeit, auch bei dieser politikergeneration, nicht mehr drin ist.
Also, man muss mal sehen, die damals war sehr rund. Die generationen Politiker waren ja alle noch im Krieg. Die haben es ja alle erlebt. Und für die war es eben nicht selbstverständlich, sondern war eigentlich dann erst die generation der jüngeren Politiker unter Kohl, für die dann halt anfing diese Selbstverständlichkeit des Systems, also die deren Sozialisierung mehr so in den 60ern und 70ern war, wo halt einfach nicht mehr dieses es kann sich auch jeden Tag wieder alles ändern drin war, sondern klar war, das ist halt für die Ewigkeit angelegt und dieses System Bundesrepublik wird in alle Ewigkeit so weiter erpapertuitiert.
Das ist so ein Tipp, den ich geben kann, den ich selber mal gemacht habe. Es gilt für Literatur, Kunst und für Politik. Man muss sich immer ganz genau angucken, wer wie alt genau war zwischen 1939 und 1945. Es ist ein großer Unterschied, ob jemand 18 war oder 14 war. Also es ist ein großer Unterschied, ob man Heinrich Böll war, der bereits als Soldat in den Krieg zog, als Erwachsene oder ob man Günter Gras war, der noch ein Kind war und erst im Laufe des Krieges halt so ein halbwegs 16 Jahre war dann. Das gilt auch für Politik. Es ist ein Unterschied, ob man wie Willy Brandt, das gilt auch für die DDR übrigens, ob man den Krieg erlebt hat oder das den Hitler erlebt hat, bereits im Erwachsenenstatus oder ob man 14 war, ob man 15 war, ob man 16 war. Und das sehen Sie auch bei Kohl. Kohl ist der Jüngste in der ganzen Riegel. Der hat den Krieg nur noch als Junge erlebt. Das ist sozusagen die einzige wirkliche Erfahrung mit dem Krieg für ihn jetzt. Faktisch war, dass er als Hitlerjunge da nach München beordert wurde, um die Ruinen aufzuräumen. Und darum ist er auch der Letzte in der gesamten Reihe. Der hat gerade noch sagen können, weil sein Bruder gefallen ist und sein Vater den Krieg erlebt hat und er daran natürlich desah, hat gerade noch sagen können, nie wieder Krieg. Während die anderen, wie Helmut Schmidt, von dem wir ja wissen, dass er sogar beim 20. Juli in dem Gerichtssaal saß, Richard von Weizsäcker, der an der Ostfront war, das ist nochmal ein ganz anderes Kaliber, das oder Wehner.
Die waren schon politisch erwachsen zu dem Zeitpunkt.
Die waren politisch erwachsen und dann hört es plötzlich auf. Dann ist es plötzlich wie nie geschehen. Dann ist es praktisch nur noch Rhetorik. Das erleben wir jetzt ja in der Europadebatte. Ist das Wort, wir wollen nie wieder Krieg, in dem Sinne, wie Kohl es noch verwendet hat, eigentlich noch überzeugend oder nicht? Also für Herrn Rösler offenbar ist es kein Argument mehr, denn seine Europadebatte läuft jetzt ja ganz anders.
Ich finde es ja faszinierend, dass die ganzen Aufrüstungssachen dann aber doch unter Kanzlern stattgefunden haben, die es eigentlich noch erlebt haben und die es hätten besser wissen können. Gerade der Adenauer hat ja da üble Dinge gemacht. Dem kann man wirklich nicht die politische Reife absprechen, während der Kriegsjahre. Der hat das ja alles noch nicht verstanden.
Ja, Adenauer ist, das muss man sich auch mal vorstellen, ich meine diese Bundesrepublik, die Geschichte. Wir müssen uns mal festhalten, Adenauer ist wesentlich älter als Adolf Hitler. Also der Bundeskanzler, ich weiß nicht ob 15 Jahre oder so, ich weiß es jetzt nicht genau. Der Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik Deutschland war älter als Hitler, also sozusagen fast schon eine generation darüber, ging aufs Gymnasium in der Bismarckzeit. Das war der Mann, der dann die erste Kanzlerin wurde, wobei ich da jetzt widersprechen würde, mit Schlimmes gemacht, die, sie haben ja keinen Krieg begonnen, aber was sie gesagt haben und wovon sie überzeugt waren, war, Hitler ist deshalb eine Gefahr gewesen, weil es keine, sozusagen weil die anderen sich nicht gewehrt haben. Bei denen ging es ja bei der Wiederaufrüstung, da war ich auch noch nicht geboren, als das debattiert wurde, ging es ja um die Frage, wenn wir es uns wehren können, das ist bis heute ungeklärt, ob das der richtige Weg war oder der falsche Weg war. Und auch bei Helmut Schmidt ging es darum, wir dürfen uns nie wieder von einem nichtdemokratischen System einschüchtern lassen und bei Helmut Kohl. Punkt ist aber, der erste Krieg, der die Deutschen führte, wurde nicht von dieser generation geführt, sondern dann von der pazifistischen generation danach. Das darf man nicht vergessen. Das war Joschka Fischer als Außenminister. Das ist ja ein wirklich interessanter Vorgang.
Also die konnten dann eigentlich wieder, ne?
Die konnten wieder und die haben dann auch wirklich schamlos instrumentalisiert. Nie wieder Auschwitz als Kriegsbegründung auf dem Balkan und so weiter. Das haben wir ja alles erlebt.
Also das war immer so eine Sache, die ich nicht verstehen konnte, weil wie wir so schnell nach dem Krieg wieder eine Bundeswehr kriegen konnten. Weil ich mein, das...
Das ist nur aus der systemkonfrontation zu verstehen.
Ja, natürlich, aber...
Also ich mein, das geht halt, kannste halt nicht verstehen, ohne Betrachtung dieser, ja, der wahrgenommenen Bedrohung. Also meine Bildung über die Bundesrepublik zu dieser Zeit kommt ja daher, dass ich, nachdem ich irgendwie nach der Wende habe, ich angefangen zu studieren und im Westen und hab dann irgendwie meine Pausen zwischen den Seminaren draußen in der FU verbracht im Polizistikarchiv und hab mir halt meine Geschichte der Bundesrepublik dadurch angelesen, da stehen halt diese ganzen Reihen mit irgendwie Quick, wie damals noch eine richtige Zeitung war, und Stern, die damals auch noch eine richtige Zeitung war, und Spiegel und so. Und man kann das halt alles da lesen, also auch so hauptsächlich auf Papier. Und da versteht man dann plötzlich auch wie diese Bedrohung durch den Osten, also wie gegenständlich die war. Und dass die erst so eigentlich in den 70ern so in den Hintergrund fadeete und irgendwie davor doch durchaus sehr plastisch war und es auch immer wieder irgendwelche Dinge gab, irgendwelche Grenz zwischen Fälle und Überläufer und spionage und all sowas war ja richtig Tagsthema, Korea-Krieg, Vietnam-Krieg, ja.
War das im Osten genauso eigentlich?
Ja.
Also auch richtig Angst, dass der Westen jetzt kommen könnte.
Ja, das war ja bis in die 80er-Hinteren, dass die sowjetunion war ja der Meinung, dass mit Regen dann, dass es halt einen Überfall geben würde.
Na gut, das war ja nun auch tatsächlich begründbar, der Mann war ja nun.
Das war halt diese Madman Strategie.
Also für meine generation, ich bin in den 70er-Jahren aufs Gymnasium gekommen, waren Sätze wie geh doch nach drüben oder die Russen kommen schon grotesk. Also das muss ich sagen. Das sagten bestimmte Leute und man glaubte es nicht. Aber noch mal zu der systemkonfrontation. Das ist ja genau, was Frank Rieger sagt, das ist ja genau der Punkt. Und das ist etwas, was wir haben unglaubliche Lebenslügen in der Geschichte der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, die noch alle gar nicht aufgearbeitet sind. Bereits am Nürnberger Kriegsverbrecherprozess, das kann man alles bei Albert Speer nachlesen, dachten wohlgemerkt die Hauptangeklagten der Nazis dort, sie kommen noch mal alle davon, weil es ja über Berichtete wie Göring triumphierend aus der Zeitung vorliest, dass jetzt die Russen und die Amerikaner Konflikte haben. Beim Koreakrieg war Speer überzeugt, dass er dann rauskommt aus Spandau und so weiter. Das heißt diese, und es sind ja auch viele alte Nazi-Generäle, das wissen wir ja alles, das heißt diese systemkonfrontation insgesamt war so stark, dass es sogar möglich schien, also ich meine, es ist ja dann so glücklich passiert, dass sogar diese Kriegsverbrecher noch mal irgendwie eine Chance haben in dieser Gesellschaft.
Da hatten sie ja zum Teil auch nicht mal sowohl am Westen, aber die Akelen sag ich nur.
Ich meine jetzt die Nürnberger, also die wirklich, die dann auch hingerichtet wurden usw. Aber jetzt nochmal zurück zu dieser Rhetorik. Wir wollten ja über politische Rhetorik. Ich kann das auch nur empfehlen, das hab ich auch, da war ich zu klein. Willy Brandt erklärt den Deutschen die Ostverträge. Das haben sie nicht erlebt. Ich hab's erlebt, ich meine, das klingel ich selber so, wie so einer von denen, ich weiß, dass der Hausmeister in unserer Schule, der Hausmeister permanent das radio hatte, laufen hatte über die Debatte im Bundestag. Das hatte offenbar so das Gefühl Zukunft Deutschlands oder was auch immer. Und wenn man jetzt sich diese Rede von Willy Brandt anguckt, dieser Satz, also der wirklich Gänsehaut, wenn ich den nenne, es wird nichts aufgegeben, was nicht längst verspielt wurde. Das ist, wie er das auch sagt, das ist auch so groß, auch dieses Wort verspielt wurde oder so ähnlich, also im Sinne von, ihr seid ja selber daran schuld. Ich muss sagen, da kenne ich kein Äquivalent, also keinen Vergleich seither in der politischen Rhetorik.
Ich hatte irgendwie noch eben Hinweis, sich mal so ein paar alte, den paar alten Debatten anzugucken und den großen Reden. Was mir da halt auffiel, ist, dass ich mich nicht erinnern kann, wann ich die letzte große Rede im Bundestag gehört. Aber im Sinne von einer Rede im Zizoro-Sinne, die halt eine richtige Rede ist. Mit einem dramaturgischen Aufbau und irgendwie...
Ist doch eigentlich eine Frechheit, oder?
Irgendwie ist es halt immer nur so dieses, aber ja, meine Damen und Herren, wir müssen uns alle darüber einig sein, dass vielleicht hier doch noch... Also das Ganze gebabbelt.
Ist das nicht eine Frechheit? Das ist doch deren Auftrag.
Und die andere Frechheit, finde ich ja, die mir jetzt gerade in den letzten Tagen so auffiel, da sitzt halt niemand mehr.
Da habe ich einen wunderbaren Tweet gelesen. Ja, nehmt es den Leuten doch nicht übel, dass die da nicht sind, denn es ist ja schließlich Mittwoch und die Abgeordneten wollen ja zum Wochenende zu Hause sein.
Ah, jawoll, so sieht's aus.
Aber ich meine, das verleiht einem auch das Gefühl, dass es nicht dringend ist. Wenn man sich so eine Debatte ansieht, ich meine, wir können ja froh sein, dass es inzwischen Phoenix gibt, den gab es ja auch nicht immer. Und dass da in Berlin gibt es im Kabelnetz Parlamentsfernsehen-Kanal, da kann man, wenn man will, hingucken. Aber das ist wirklich deprimierend.
Wobei Phoenix auch mittlerweile immer seltener überträgt.
Aber wenn man da mal was sieht, sitzt da so gut wie nie jemand. Die ersten zwei Reihen sitzen voll, damit es jemand zum Applaudieren gibt. Aber das Gefühl, hier geht es gerade um was, stellt sich nicht ein.
Das ist der Punkt. Dass es um was geht. Meine letzte Erinnerung an eine große Rede war die von Richard von Walzacker vom 8. Mai. Die habe ich auch ganz bewusst erlebt. Seitdem ist ja wirklich einiges geschehen. Ich erinnere mich auch nicht. Wir hatten Kriegszustände, wir haben Armeen losgeschickt, wir hatten eine Wiedervereinigung, wir hatten eine Euro-Krise, was auch immer. Ich erinnere mich an überhaupt keine Rede. Das, denken Sie an den Bundespräsidenten, an den Amtierenden vor allen Dingen. Von denen kenne ich überhaupt keine Rede.
Hat doch schon mal einer gehalten?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Oh ja, oh ja, das ist ganz furchtbar. Das kann man überhaupt nicht aushalten.
Ich weiß, er hat jetzt gerade einen Abgesagt.
Der redet auch sehr langsam. Ich glaube, er versucht so zu simulieren, dass er mit Bedacht redet, aber wenn du das hörst, das hält man wirklich nicht aus.
Und dann fragt man sich doch, wieso will er, wollte er das werden? Weil das ist ja das Amt. Das Amt ist ja mit Sprache. Sie haben keine Zitzero. Wir sehen doch am Internet, was Sprache für eine Magie hat. Das ist ja unglaublich. Und warum will er dann das Amt? Das ist ein ganz großes Rätsel. Ob das Disrespect ist oder ob das Unfähigkeit ist, ich weiß es nicht. Es ist jedenfalls verheerend. Seit der Wiedervereinigung wartet jeder. Erinnern Sie sich, wie immer es hieß, wir brauchen eine Blutschweiß- und Tränenrede?
Genau.
Das Lustige ist ja, dass wir die auf Umwegen von Obama gekriegt haben dann. Es gab ja in Deutschland mehr Rückhalt für Obama als in den USA-Stellen.
Weil er reden konnte.
Ja, weil er einfach reden konnte. Der hat sich dahingestellt und hat ein paar Sätze gesagt, das muss ja gar keine volle Rede sein, wir haben ja keine großen Ansprüche, aber gelegentlich das Gefühl haben, liebe Landsleute, ich nehme es jetzt in die Hand. Das sind die Probleme, die werden wir jetzt angehen. Ja, und es steht hier viel auf dem Spiel. Daher gucken sie sich das bitte an, es geht hier um was. Einfach mehr will man noch gar nicht hören.
Ich finde auch, man sollte klar machen, wir sind ja da gebrannte Kinder, niemand erwartet jetzt hier Sportpalastreden, niemand will jetzt hier Demagogie oder so etwas. Aber es geht.
Die Demagogie haben wir im Bundestag ja gehabt, irgendwie am Mittwoch, von Herrn Uhl.
Ja, das stimmt.
Gut, aber nicht ganz freiwillig.
Die war aber jetzt...
Ja gut, das war vor allem was Amateurhaftes, aber Demagogie muss man ja nicht so sagen. Also ich muss ja sagen, in meiner Historie, ich war zu der Erdzeit ein Agitator.
Wobei das ja, muss man erklären für die Wessis, das ist nicht unbedingt negativ besetzt, der Ausdruck Agitator, nicht wahr?
Also der Agitator war in der Struktur im Osten zuständig dafür, dass die politische information, der zum Beispiel der Klasse, gewährleistet ist. Und das heißt, das muss ja so was wie eine Wandzettung machen mit den Themen des Tages und so.
Eigentlich machen wir das ja immer noch jetzt gerade.
Aber zumindest hatten wir damals ein bisschen Anspruch daran, was die Qualität der Propaganda angeht. Und diese Sachen, die jetzt der Ull da brachte, das war ja sowas von amateurhafter.
Auch die Bösewichter sind Amateure geworden.
Das ist es ja. Das zieht sich auch durch unsere Kritik.
Wir haben uns ja damit abgefunden als Bürger, dass wir belogen werden. Aber wir möchten gern glaubwürdig belogen werden.
Erzähl doch mal diese Geschichte mit dem Ull jetzt. Die müssen wir doch mal hier gerade spielen.
Na ja, also es ging halt damit los, dass der da seine Rede wohl relativ freigehalten hat, was im Bundestag wohl eher unüblich ist.
Was eigentlich ja lobenswert ist.
Eigentlich ist es lobenswert, aber der hat sich halt ein paar Mal vergriffen. Ein paar Mal kann man sagen, gut hat er sich versprochen. Aber es gibt im Bundestag erstens einen Livestream inzwischen, sehr lobenswert. Man kann also, auch wenn man nicht in Berlin wohnt, sich diesen Stream angucken. Das haben beim CTC einige gemacht, als es um den Trojaner ging, weil wir dachten so, jetzt kommt hier endlich mal, jetzt kommen hier die großen Gewehre aus dem Keller. Und es gibt danach ein Protokoll. Und was Insider schon immer wussten, dieses Protokoll wird also nicht live erstellt und entspricht nicht unbedingt dem Gesagten, sondern das geht nochmal durch die Büros von den jeweiligen Beratern.
Zuerst steganografiert, also es gibt da zwei Sachen. Es gibt einmal die Reden, die vorher auch abgegeben werden können. Manchmal ist die Rede zur Protokollgebe.
Das ist jetzt nicht gewesen.
Das ist ein anderes Thema, sind wir auch furchtbare Sachen.
Aber wenn sie halt gehalten wird, dann wird sie ja mitsteganografiert.
Aber diese version landet eben nicht im Internet und ist auch nicht der offizielle Record, sondern es gibt diesen stenografischen Dienst, der Kryptograph bricht durch mit mir. Es gibt den stenografischen Dienst des Bundestages, der macht dieses Stenoprotokoll und gibt es dann aber dem jeweiligen Redner bzw. seinem Büro. Und die können dann Fehler korrigieren. Aber in den Regeln steht eben ausdrücklich drin, es darf nicht sinnend stellen korrigiert werden. Also es darf auch, aber dann braucht man eine Ausnahmegenehmigung vom Präsidenten des Bundestages und so weiter. Was jetzt passiert ist, ist, der Ull hat sich halt im Kopf von Kragen geredet, hat dann sehr knackige Sprüche abgesondert. Der eine war...
Die Sicherheitsbehörden regieren das Land.
Genau, also Sicherheitsbehörden regieren das Land. Und es wäre ja tragisch, wenn dieses Land von Piraten und Chaoten aus dem Computerklub regiert würde. Und fing dann nochmal an, dass die Sicherheitsabteilungen, die ja unser Land regieren würden, und die Sicherheitsbeamten, die seien ja gut geschult und würden das alles schon in Ordnung machen. Aber er hat jedenfalls das so dargestellt, als wenn die Regierung Teil der Exekutive wäre und quasi von den BKA-Beamten unser Land geleitet würde. Und das kann man jetzt sagen, okay, war ein Versprecher oder nicht. Aber das Stehenow-Protokoll hat es halt komplett geändert. Da standen dann drin nicht, wir werden regiert von Sicherheitsbeamten, sondern wir haben Sicherheitsbeamte, die auf dieses und jenes achten.
Also wir sind der Sache auch nachgegangen, weil mich interessierte das, ob er, er hat mich ja auch in der Rede beleidigt. Für meinen Leitartikel, ob er das auch verändert hat, das war aber leider oder zum Glück nicht der Fall. Man muss sagen, es sieht so aus, dass der stenografische Dienst offenbar stillschweigend erkennbare Versprecher korrigiert. Also ob er da selber war oder ob das der stenografische Dienst war, ist ja egal, es gibt immer noch Sieg und Freud, ehe es spricht. Und dann ist das nochmal eine ganz andere Stenogramm der Seele, wenn man so will, aber schon eine Sache.
Aber interessant war, was die reaktion war.
Die reaktion war, dass diese manipulation hat eine deutlich größere reaktion hervorgerufen als die eigentlichen Sachen, die er da gesagt hat. Weil einem Großteil der Bevölkerung es eigentlich überhaupt nicht bewusst war, dass diese Protokolle nicht Protokolle im Sinne sind, wie wir sie benutzen. Denn wenn man zum Beispiel eine Mitarbeitersitzung macht oder irgendwie eine Vorstandssitzung in einem Unternehmen und es gibt ein Protokoll und man fälscht, was da drin steht, das ist richtig strafbewehrt, das darf man nicht tun. Und das ist so der Art, das ist, was die Bevölkerung unter Protokoll versteht.
Und gerade die Nerds.
Gerade die Nerds, na klar. Und als die gesehen haben, dass diese Protokolle im Grunde eher so eine Art, ich will nicht sagen Whitewash, aber da geht es halt nicht darum, konkret...
Eine offizielle Geschichtsschreibung sind.
Genau, das ist die offizielle Geschichte.
Sehr schöne Euphorie, vielen Dank. Sondern dass da eben korrigiert wird. Das hat einen einen richtigen Aufschrei gegeben. Der Ull war jetzt, sagtest du, zwei Tage lang in Folge.
Training-Topic, ja.
Training-Topic auf Twitter.
Ja, was man ja auch verstehen kann, wenn man einfach... Ich wusste das übrigens auch nicht. Also ich gehe davon aus, das ist für mich auch wichtig, weil man geht ja an alte Protokolle so ran, dass man auch versucht, so die Psychic Battle, also das psychische Schlachtfeld zu... Und das geht offenbar nicht. Also wenn die das immer so korrigieren. Es gibt natürlich legendäre Sachen, die in den Protokollen stehen. Also Franz Josef Strauß, berühmte Äußerung an Todenhöfer, den er ja immer *** nannte und solche Dinge, das wurde nicht korrigiert. Dafür gab es... Der hat Schlimme. Wehner hatte eine permanente... Weil wir von großen Reden reden. Wehner war besessen von so, ich will nicht sagen sexuellen Anspielungen, aber so pubertären sexualisierten Anspielungen. Da gibt es die übelsten oder... Ich weiß nicht, ob man das hier in diesem seriösen Sender sagen kann. Also zum Beispiel ganz schlimm hat er dem Arm von Donani mitgespielt, den er nicht mochte, weil er den für eitel und glatt hielt. Und dann sagt er halt öfter, auch vor laufender Kamera, steht auch in seiner biografie, jetzt geht er wieder...... und das war natürlich jetzt nicht große Rede, sondern das war eher Partheia.
Okay, aber das ist noch so ein Detail, was ich mich erinnern kann, dass früher noch so zu Zeiten, wo ich als Kind Westfernsehen geguckt habe, da kam es durchaus mal vor, dass irgendwie so Kindersendungen denn verschoben wurden oder so war noch eine Debatte im Bundestag.
Das habe ich erlebt, wir waren ersetzt, wir wollten Kinderstunde sehen und es war immer schwarz-weiß, es war auch immer nur eine Kameraeinstellung. Ich weiß noch, wer da alles, Herr Katzer und Leute, die ich heute niemand mehr kenne. Und wir fanden das jetzt auch nicht toll. Also das war schon, später hat man dann schon gemerkt, es gab so Schlüsselmomente und da, also Franz Josef Strauß, Herbert Wehner, hat sich niemand entgehen lassen. Das war wirklich auch vom Temperament, von der Risikobereitschaft. Natürlich ganz, Strauß war ein unglaublicher Redner.
Ich glaube, da gibt es auf YouTube übrigens auch ein paar beste Videos.
Ja, da gibt es ganz, ganz, großartig.
Aber interessant fand ich eben genau diese priorisierung. Heute würde niemand mehr das Sandmännchen wegen der Bundestagsrede verschieben.
Das ist ja auch, was ich mit Phoenix meine. Die Hierarchisierung, was nehmen wir, ja, was nehmen wir wichtig? Das war ja nicht das Sandmännchen, das war das Ding ab 15 Uhr. Und stundenlang, manchmal auf beiden Sendern, muss ja nicht so unbedingt sein, aber was hierarchisieren Medien? Was nehmen sie wichtig? Was nehmen sie nicht wichtig? Was ist Schlagzeile? Das ist ja, was wir alle beim Öffentlich-Rechtlichen nicht verstehen, warum sie nicht um 20.15 Uhr wenigstens einmal in der Woche ein politisches Magazin machen, um zu sagen, das hat einen wirklichen Stellenwert in der Gesellschaft und nicht nur eine Talkshow oder so etwas. Und das ist etwas völlig, das ist jetzt eine Nische geworden, die Politik. Das muss man so sehen, jedenfalls die Realpolitik. Und das zeigt es zumindest die medialen Systeme, nicht die Zeitung würde ich jetzt sagen, die machen das noch, die nicht so anders. Der Lammert hat ja eine riesige Auseinandersetzung mit den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen darüber, weil sie den Bundestag nicht mehr übertragen. Jetzt kann man auch sagen, das will auch heute niemand mehr hören. Man kann aber auch sagen, vielleicht geht es um nichts mehr.
Da gab es auch diese Äußerung von dem Merz, wie war denn das?
Ja, Friedrich Merz, das habe ich damals sehr attackiert. Da fiel ich fast zum Stuhl. Das muss man mal wirklich sagen. Ich glaube, die einflussreichste Sendung leider für das Entstehen des Neoliberalismus war die Sendung Sabine Christ Jansen. Auch damals war ein neues Format. Viele werden sich noch erinnern, waren auch fast immer die gleichen Gäste. Sie selber war ziemlich deutlich Partei. Und da gab es eben den Moment, wo Friedrich Merz, es gab zwei Momente, der eine bei der 100. Sendung, als der Bundespräsident Horst Köhler als Gast dort hingeht und die gesamte Geschichtsschreibung dieser Sendung unterordnete. Wissen Sie, das war bei ihrer 50. Sendung, als das passierte und bei ihrer ist das schon irre. Und dann Friedrich Merz, der sagte, den legendären Satz, Ihre Sendung ist wichtiger als die Reden im Deutschen Bundestag und meinungsbildender. Das ist schon eine Zäsur gewesen.
Das ist auch traurig, weil die Gäste ja immer auch so Lobby-Gestalten von der neuen sozialen Marktwirtschaft und so waren. Also das war ja, die haben ja gar nicht mal versucht.
Ja und man kann sich ja auch, wenn sie sich zum Beispiel mal so eine Sendung angucken und auch noch dazu zählen, dass der Moderator ja auch bezahlt wird vom öffentlich-rechtlichen System, muss man sich immer mal fragen, wer dort eigentlich nicht vom Staat bezahlt wird, von denen, die dort reden. Da bleiben meistens nur entweder funktionäre übrig oder Lobbyisten. Das ist eine ganz merkwürdige Verzerrung von Wirklichkeit.
Manchmal sind wir auch da.
Selten genug. Über die Trojaner haben sie eben keine Talkshow gemacht. Ich meine, ich habe mit dem einen oder anderen geredet, habe gesagt, warum macht ihr das nicht? Da kann man doch so viel dranhängen. Es geht ja nicht nur um die Trojaner, es geht auch um viel mehr. Und was mir da geantwortet wurde, war eben erschütternd. Das war Quote, das interessiert die Frau nicht zum Beispiel, zu schwierig und solche Dinge.
Die haben das ja versucht, als es um die Vorratsdatenspeicherung ging. Da ist ja ein Lobo, das Lobo ist da noch durch die Gegend gezogen und hat einen Talkshow gedreht. Wir waren ja schon in so ein paar Talkshows, wo wir auch waren, aber jetzt halt gerade nicht.
In so ein paar Talkshows waren wir schon drin, aber was wir auch feststellen, ist, dass das Niveau der Thematisierung in den Medien allgemein sich ja schon dramatisch verändert. Also die Zeitungen sind ja durchaus noch eine lübliche Ausnahme, sofern sie nicht einfach nur dpa Printouts sind.
Man tut sich einfach auch kein Gefallen, wenn man zu so einer Talkshow geht.
Naja gut, ich meine, das ist halt eben die Frage. Das Format ist eben auch so verschlissen, dass es nur noch sehr wenige, was heißt die Phoenix-Runde zum Beispiel, kann man noch machen oder so. Weil es zumindest noch irgendwie irgendeine Art von inhaltlichem politischen Anspruch dabei gibt. Aber bei vielen Sachen geht es ja nicht einmal mehr darum.
Es geht nicht mehr um die Wahrheitsfindung. Auch bei dieser Phoenix-Runde war ich wirklich betroffen, dass der Moderator nicht an opportuner Stelle einfach mal nachgehakt hat.
Aber was sie bekommen ist emotionales Kapital. Das haben sie gesehen, dass durch zwei oder drei Talkshows, die Piraten, da geht es gar nicht darum, was da gesagt wurde, sondern die Piraten, dass die Gesellschaft eine emotion, ein Gefühl entwickelt für die Piraten. Das war die eine Will-Sendung und auch eine andere. Aber das andere, also die Fragen, die uns jetzt ja auch so betreffen, also die Fragen, wo sind die Antworten, wo sind die Fragen, die könnten sie in Formaten ja lösen. Zum Beispiel gibt es hinter den Kulissen den Versuch, den ich super finde, aber erst gescheitert, den Chef der Bundesbank mal ganz alleine Hauptsendezeit eine Stunde oder anderthalb Stunden nur ihn zu befragen über die Lage, die wir haben in der Eurozone.
Also was ist denn eigentlich los?
Genau, und das nächste, nächsten Tag wieder ein anderer, nur den Hardtalk.
Das muss man aber live machen, sonst wird das alles...
Die BBC hat das Format Hardtalk und das hat sich nicht die, die das wollten, haben sich damit nicht durchsetzen können bei der ARD, weil sie das nicht wollten. Und das ist das... Das eine ist so eine Talkshow, die dafür sorgt, dass man sagt, der ist sympathisch, der ist nicht sympathisch, aber dass wir gar nicht mehr durchstoßen auf die Fakten. Leute, wir wollen doch sehen, ob jemand... Es gibt eine legendäre, kann ich auch bei YouTube, glaube ich, ablauchrufbar BBC-Sendung mit Wolfgang Schäuble vor 2 oder 3 Jahren. Hardtalk heißt die. Der wird dort so hart angegangen. Und am Ende kapiert man was. Und das fehlt bei uns halt total. Also ich kenne keine einzige Sendung, wo es das gibt. Das wäre ja der Moment der Wahrheit.
Ich glaube aber auch nicht, dass die BBC das heute noch etablieren könnte, sondern die Sendung gibt es halt schon echt lange.
Stimmt.
Und wenn man heute... Also das ist auch eine ganz andere Streitkultur. Das kann ich auch jedem mal empfehlen, der mal in England zu Besuch ist. Da gibt es noch richtige... Also das ist auch ein Ritual, aber da gibt es richtige Befragung des Premierministers, im Unterhaus, wo dann auch wirklich böse Fragen gestellt werden. Und nicht so eine Soft-Belle wie bei uns. Und da kann der dann auch nicht einfach mal auf was anderes antworten, sondern muss dann auch zu dieser Fragestellung nehmen. Und das ist so richtig zack, zack, zack vom Timing her sehr schnell. Und sowas würde ich mir auch bei uns wünschen. Aber das ist eben... Die Medien sind bei uns dazu übergegangen, dass die Leute eben damit durchkommen, wenn sie auf Fragen nicht antworten. Die können einfach eine andere Frage beantworten. Das ist ja auch... Das wird ja in Schulungen beigebracht heutzutage, in Polit-Schulungen, wie man in Talkshows oder bei Befragungen einfach die Fragen ignoriert und seine Agenda runter erzählt. Und die Moderatoren lassen einen damit durchkommen, weil das eben heute Standard ist. Und solange wir das nicht wegkriegen, sehe ich auch keine Besserung, ehrlich gesagt. Was soll denn da noch groß geschehen? Ja, dass auch diesen Bundestagspräsidenten, Bundesbankpräsidenten, wenn man den jetzt hinsetzt, das funktioniert ja auch nur, wenn man die dann nicht davon kommen lässt.
Nein, das ist genau der Punkt. Da muss auf der Gegenseite jemand sitzen, der die Fragen stellt. Es darf halt nicht so sein, wie es im öffentlich-rechtlichen System, die ich verteidige, zum Teil ist, dass in einem dem ZDF der Landesgruppenleiter eines Bundeslandes, erster Ministerpräsidenten, sich gut stellen muss, ehe er überhaupt zum Landesgruppenchef, zum Landeschef wird. Das sind Dinge, die sich im Laufe der Zeit, oder die Christiane sind, die ja praktisch Mitspielerin war, im politischen System. Ich glaube, dass das aber alles in dieser Krise, in der wir uns jetzt befinden, darum reden wir ja auch jetzt über politische Rhetorik, weil wir das Gefühl haben, irgendwie fehlt, es fehlt irgendwie, es fehlt Diskurs. Also es muss etwas erklärt werden und dann können daraus Konsequenzen gezogen werden.
Aber das, was Fefe gerade sagte, ist natürlich ein wichtiger Punkt. Das ist nämlich die Qualität des Personals. Also die Leute, die da sind, hat natürlich einen massiven Einfluss auf die Debatte. Und natürlich auch der Fakt, dass wir dieses zu Todes-Spinnen von Themen, dass es so normal geworden ist, also dass wir uns einfach daran gewöhnt haben, dass es keine richtigen Antworten gibt. Hier Olo Schröder, der Vorgast von einem Bundestag.
Ein Musterbeispiel.
Ein Musterbeispiel von irgendwie, wir geben keine Antworten mehr, wir liefern nur noch irgendwie hohle Phrasen ab. Es gibt kein Recht mehr auf irgendwie eine inhaltliche Aussage. Offenbar.
Aber dann habe ich eine Frage. Vergessen wir mal für ein paar Sekunden alles, was in der zweiten Hälfte von Gutenberg passiert ist. Vergessen wir alles mal wegstreichen. Und auch jetzt nicht ihn als Witzfigur, sondern einfach so, wie er war. Wenn sie und ich hatte daran, wir haben ja damals auch mal drüber geredet, ich bin ja damals schon irre geworden daran. Es ging ja gar nicht jetzt um die Politik, sondern es ging um einen Satz, der immer wieder kam. Wenigstens einer, der Klartext redet, hieß es. Wenigstens einer, der die Wahrheit sagt. Und ich rede jetzt nur vom ersten Teil dieser Karriere. Das stimmt erkennbar einfach nicht. Also da musste man nicht irgendwie kundig sein. Schon bei der Opelsache ist der ja nicht zurückgetreten. Also das war ja gar nicht der, hier stehe ich und kann nicht anders. Aber viele Medien, nicht alle, aber vor allen Dingen auch die Bevölkerung hat das Label entwickelt, hier spricht einer Klartext. Bei einem, der wahrscheinlich am wenigsten von allen Klartexts geredet hat.
War es nicht Ihr Bild, das das Label entwickelt hat?
Das haben so viele Leute.
Das war so wie eine Echo-Kammer, aber wenn man das einmal reingibt, verstärkt sich das.
Das war unglaublich.
Also mein Empfinden war ja eher, dass es tatsächlich die Springer-Medien waren.
Stern, Spiegel Online.
Die haben alle diese Klartexts auch?
Weiß ich noch heute, wie Spiegel Online, als er in Afghanistan war, schrieb er, er ist kälter und härter als Hillary Clinton und solche Dinge. Das haben wir alles mal dokumentiert in der Zeit. Mir geht es ja auch gar nicht darum, dem Mann jetzt noch mal einen Karren zu fahren.
Gut, aber das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Das würde zu sagen, das Empfinden von Klartext bei jemandem, der nur eine andere Art von Sprechblasen absonnerte.
Naja, ich habe das ja damals unter dem Aspekt gesehen, dass ich damals gerade auf Geschäftsreise in den USA war, gerade zurückkam. Und das war exakt die Phrase, mit der der Buschstein Wahlkampf betrieben hat. In beiden Wahlen, wo er gewählt wurde. Das war genau die Phrase, ich bin ein Cowboy, ich habe zwar keine Ahnung, aber ich rede wenigstens Klartext. Das war genau dieses Ding und ich glaube, das haben die einfach kopiert.
Aber wie kann es sein, das verstehe ich, wie kann es sein, dass jemand, der erkennbar kein Klartext spricht, denn das ist absolut definitiv sicher.
Der Busch doch auch nicht.
Ja, Moment, dass der dann aber so wahrgenommen wird. Und das war nicht nur die BILD-Zeitung. Das ist eine Frage, ob nicht, sozusagen simulationen oder die simulation von Straightness, ob das nicht reicht schon. Und das ist nämlich auch beunruhigend, weil man sieht, da ist eine Marktlücke offenbar für so etwas und die kann ganz schnell gefüllt werden. Ich könnte das wirklich hier hundertfach belegen, dass diese These stimmt, bis hin zu heute Journal-Interviews. Ich bin einer, der dafür bekannt ist, dass er sagt, die ganze Sache mit dem Krieg, das hieß kriegsähnliche Zustände vorher und dann ist es vielleicht doch ein Krieg und so. Das ist nicht Klartext gewesen.
Na ja, gut, aber ich erinnere mich tatsächlich...
Aber das ist doch die Erbwase.
Diese Kriegsgeschichte war tatsächlich so ein Punkt, da kann ich mich auch total erinnern, das ist richtig, wo er das eher zum ersten Mal überhaupt von irgendwie...
Kriegsähnliche Zustände.
Das Wort Krieg überhaupt in den Mund nahm. Und er einfach nur das Offensichtliche sagte.
Er sagte erst Kriegsähnliche?
Ah, jetzt habe ich es. Was er tut, was er getan hat, war, er hat nur ein bisschen weniger Spin da reingetan. Zu jeder Zeit gibt es ja diese Tabus in der Gesellschaft, worum es geht und alle wissen, was los ist, aber sich nur am Rand die Leute trauen, das zu sagen. In unserer Zeit gibt es eine Menge Sachen davon. Der Krieg in Afghanistan war das erste, wo alle eben ist klar, es ist Krieg, nur die Politiker sagen es nicht so. Geht weiter mit Euro-Krise, mit Finanzkrise, mit Peak Oil. Also alle wesentlichen großen Sachen unserer Zeit sind ja irgendwann mal Tabus gewesen. Also Sachen, die nicht öffentlich gesagt werden konnten. Und alles, was er getan hat, war, ein bisschen davon abzukratzen, also ein bisschen hinzugehen zu, wir deckeln es mal nicht ganz so dolle zu.
Ich will den Fall jetzt ja gar nicht vertiefen.
Ich finde ihn spannend, weil irgendwie ein Hinweis ist, auf was kommen wird.
Auf was kommen wird. Das glaube ich nämlich auch. Nehmen wir nur mal ganz kurz, ich weiß, es klingt ja langweilig, aber nochmal diese opel-situation. Die kenne ich zufälligerweise sehr genau, was da genau los war. Was war passiert? Die wollten diesen Opel retten und der Bundeswirtschaftsminister sagt in diesem Gremium, ich kann das eigentlich nicht mittragen, ich müsste mir da echt überlegen, ob ich das weitermache und dann das hören ungefähr zehn Leute von 50. Das dringt noch nicht mal durch und er tritt ja auch nicht zurück. Und dann geht eine Geschichte durch die Gesellschaft, in der es heißt, das ist deshalb ein aufrechter Mann, weil der das nicht mitmachen wollte.
Ist das nicht Krisen-PR? Das ist so, was ich mich dabei frage. Dann nehmen wir mal an, ich bin der PR-Manager von Gutenberg und der verplappert sich. Das ist doch genau der Spin, den ich da dranhänge, dass ich sage, der Mann ist wenigstens ehrlich.
Nee, der hat sich nicht verplappert. Das ist Psycho. Das hat gereicht.
Das ist die nächste Level von Spinning. Mal zurückgucken. Wir hatten es ja schon mal in einer vorigen Sendung ein bisschen gecovert, wo dieses massive Spinning herkam. Das hat ja angefangen eigentlich mit Setscher. Die halt einfach ihre Politik in so dicke Layer von Neuworten eingepackt hat und von Umbauen von Konzepten, Kapern von Konzepten, Kapern von Worten. Wozu das ja geführt hat, ist, dass man halt an bestimmten Punkten heute keine Debatte mehr führen kann, wenn man überhaupt dieses Vokabular auch nur benutzt. Weil es halt nichts sagen, das nicht immer wieder umgedeutet werden kann. Und wir haben ja den Punkt erreicht, wo alle davon total genervt sind. Also selbst irgendwie so relativ honorige Personen wie Frau Lotharzer-Schnarrenberger, wo man zumindest annimmt, dass sie halt irgendwie eine gewisse Integrität zum Thema Bürgerrechte hat, hat in dieser Debatte im Bundestag effektiv nichts gesagt. Also effektiv hat sie irgendwie eine Menge Dinge gesagt, die alle ganz schön klangen.
Und der Duktus war flammend und engagiert.
Genau.
Aber inhaltlich hat sie nichts übertragen.
Und nur als kleinen Einschub, einen Tag später rief mich Gerhard Baum an und er hat am Telefon eine bessere Rede gehalten als Leutthuyser Schnarrenberger.
Das glaube ich sofort. Also ich war das halt, der ist ja auch noch einer aus der generation, die irgendwie noch richtige Reden halten konnte. Aber genau dieser Punkt, dass man halt nicht mehr die Wahrheit pur sagen kann. Ich meine, das ist auch der Grund, warum die Leute unsere Sendungen hören, weil wir ja so einen Spin nicht betreiben, sondern einfach nur sagen, was wir denken. Und genau dieses, die Wahrheit sagen können, das tritt mir auch immer wieder bei irgendwelchen Vorträgen und so. Entgegen, da kommen Leute hinterher zu mir, das ist aber gut, dass endlich mal einer die Wahrheit sagt. Und dann wiederum fängt es aber an, dass Bild genau dieses Ding kapert. Also diese Bildwerbung, jede Wahrheit braucht einen Mutigen, die sie ausspricht. So ist ja genau wieder sozusagen der nächste Spin-Dreh an dem Ding, ne?
Absolut, das ist aber nicht nur Bild. Das war der Stern, da sind viele, die da mitmachen. Das ist eine Marktlücke. Im Augenblick sitzen in dieser Marktlücke die Piraten. Die sind es ja auch, das muss man ja sagen. Aber man wird das jetzt genau, man muss auch sehr aufpassen, glaube ich, beobachten. Die werden jetzt zu diesen authentischen. Das passt genau zu dem Bild, das sie auch von sich selber geben. Aber für die Medien ist das nicht, also für die Mehrheit der Medien, hat das gar nichts mit der Realität zu tun. Die brauchen das.
Das Label der Authentizität.
Genau, das brauchen sie. Und das brauchen sie deshalb, weil sie es auch wieder zerstören wollen. Das Label der Authentizität ist nur wichtig, weil man das sehen sieht, das ist eine Medienlogik. Weil ja dann das Coole ist, der Dramaturgie, dass man dann irgendwann beweisen kann, nein, auch die nicht. Und dann stehen die Medien wieder gut da. Das hat gar nichts mehr mit Realität zu tun, also oft nicht. Das ist etwas, wo ich auch fast warnen würde, dass man sich zu viel darauf einbildet, wenn Massenmedien einem dauernd nachrufen, wie authentisch man ist. Weil das Spiel ist nochmal ein ganz anderes.
Da müssten die doch aber jetzt ständig in den Medien sein. Wieso sind sie das nicht?
Sind sie praktisch schon.
Liegt das dann denen? Also ich meine, dass die jetzt nicht in der Tagesschau befragt werden oder so?
Dass die Piraten momentan noch nicht, sagen wir mal, die große Medienoffensive schaffen, hat einfach eine Menge damit zu tun, dass sie es noch nicht handwerklich können.
Naja, das Problem ist halt...
Nichts, was irgendwie... Also kein ernsthafter Hinderungsgrund.
Ich hab das ja ein paar Mal im Blog angesprochen und ich krieg dann immer wütende Mails. Und eine der Hauptausreden ist, ja, die fragen ja gar nicht bei uns an. Und wenn die mal anfragen, dann ist es wie dieses NDR-Ding, was dann als Satire endete.
Also das wird sich jetzt dramatisch ändern, wenn es sich nicht schon geändert hat. Das ist jetzt noch auf der Ebene Mona Lisa und Länderreport und vielleicht mal eine Talkshow. Aber diese Marktlücke oder sagen wir, diese Planstelle ist frei. Die muss jetzt besetzt werden. Die Piraten brauchen jetzt halt zwei, drei Figuren, die das tun, möglichst eine Frau. Zwei Männer. Das ist ungefähr das Modell, wo es muss man so sagen, wie Medien, also der TV funktioniert und dann wird das von selber kommen. Das ist gar keine Frage. Im Augenblick ist die Euro-Krise auch zu stark und die Piraten haben sich jetzt hier beim Stroianer, hätten sie wahrscheinlich schon jede Nachrichtensendung kapern können, wenn sie sich da irgendwie geäußert hätten, was sie ja aus irgendwelchen Gründen erst mal weniger getan haben.
Also ich denke mal, wir sind ja gerade so ein bisschen bei diesem ganzen Problemkreis, politisches Personal und ich denke, das ist auch glaube ich momentan noch der größte Schwachpunkt der Piraten, dass sie halt da erst mal noch Leute rausbilden müssen, die sowohl strategisch denken können als auch Charisma haben und dadurch halt eben auch in den Medien arbeiten können. Aber ich würde sagen, das passiert einfach, wenn sie sich halt nicht irgendwie zu sehr anstellen oder zu sehr verstreiten.
Wenn sie so lange durchhalten, passiert das von alleine. Die Grünen hatten auch keinen Charisma am Anfang. Dass die CDU Charisma hat, das will ja wohl auch niemand behaupten, oder?
Ja, eben. Also, aber ich werde gut überlesen. Die SPD zwischendurch mal charismatische Figuren hatte, ja. Aber da muss man auch schon zu bis zu Wehner zurückgehen und so.
Aber es ist doch traurig, dass der Schröder rückblickend da so fast schon eine Lichtfigur ist.
Der sah aber auch nur aus wie ein Präsident.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Aber mehr nicht. Wie Kanzler. Ja, genau. Aber mehr halt auch nicht. Interessant daran ist ja doch, ist doch eben diese Anforderung, die wir ja auch implizit da transportieren. Interessant aber, wenn ich jetzt mal unser Gespräch so ein bisschen reflektiere, an kompetente Politikdarstellung, ne?
Das wollte ich nämlich gerade fragen.
Also, wo wir gerade reden, ist ja eigentlich nicht Politik, sondern tatsächlich nur Politikdarstellung.
Das war meine Frage.
Aber gibt es da überhaupt einen Unterschied?
Na, wollen sie beide, das ist ja ein richtiger Fachbegriff auch, charismatische Herrschaft. Das ist ja etwas, was die Deutschen nicht wollten, nach den Erfahrungen. Und ich merke ja in uns allen auch, dass es da eine Sehnsucht gibt. Wir haben ja auch ein paar Fälle schon beschrieben. Also, die Merkel ist das nicht. Aber wollen wir charismatische Herrschaft?
Na ja, also der Punkt ist halt, also eigentlich wollen wir von unserer Politik ja doch ein bisschen mehr unterhalten werden, als wir es so momentan tun. Also wenn wir jetzt mal unser Gespräch der letzten dreiviertel Stunde zusammenfassen.
Das ist doch der Fallback. Eigentlich will sie ja, dass sie handeln, aber wenn sie es nicht tun, dann wird es nicht so doll für sie.
Wirklich, dass sie handeln? Also ich meine, du hast doch mal dieses schöne Beispiel Belgien. So lass uns doch mal dieses hübsche Beispiel Belgien aus Graf.
Also da hab ich natürlich argumentativ nicht viel gegen gehalten, weil das ist nicht immer meine argumentation.
Ja, Belgien hat ja, weiß nicht, eineinhalb Jahre jetzt keine Regierung, sondern da wird halt immer nur so irgendwelche Interims, Zwischenlösungen, die im Grunde auch keine Befugnis haben, große Gesetze zu ändern, sondern alles, was sie machen können, ist halt dafür sorgen, dass die Gehälter ausgezahlt werden für den öffentlichen Dienst und so. Und die Steuern eingetrieben werden und das machen die eben. Und Belgien geht es nicht schlechter damit. Ja, und deswegen habe ich so ursprünglich als humorige Anekdote das immer mal angebracht und meinte, na ja, vielleicht wäre das auch für uns ein Modell. Aber inzwischen muss man wirklich sagen, wenn man vergleicht, dass die Eurozone in einer existenziellen Krise ist und die ganzen Länder alle am Abnippeln sind, dass Belgien sich da vergleichsweise deutlich besser schlägt, als die Länder, die jetzt blinden Axtenismus gemacht haben. Oder wie sagen wir, Spanien oder Irland. Und auch in Belgien gab es jetzt eine Bankprivatisierung. Also das ist nicht so, dass man auf Notfälle nicht reagieren könnte.
Einer unserer Korrespondenten, Törg Schürmer, den ich sehr bewundere, Europa-Korrespondent, der kennt das alle, die ganze Welt, die ganze Europa ist. Der sagt genau das Gleiche. Der hat immer gesagt, das geht doch super ohne Regierung. Er kennt Belgien, er hat den Fall Dutroux damals recherchiert, der kennt auch die ganzen Abgründe dort. Der sagt, das geht doch. Ich bin da jetzt nicht so sicher, ob wir das so toll finden, wenn das bei uns so wäre. Vielleicht ist das ja auch schon so. Das können wir im Augenblick nicht. Ich glaube aber, dass das genau die Fragen sind, die nach dieser charismatischen Herrschaft rufen. Dass man sagt, okay, wir wollen Performance. Und diese Performance muss irgendwas sein.
Also Show.
Ja, Show ist es. Ich glaube auch schon ehrlich gestanden, auch wenn das jetzt nicht so cool klingt, doch ein bisschen Sinn für den Ernst der Lage. Also es geht ja hier darum, dieses System, die Frau Merkel ist damals 1990 sozusagen in den Westen angekommen mit dem Gefühl, ein überlegendes System, das ja auch die rationalität auf seiner Seite hat. Wie muss ich das eigentlich anfühlen nach 20 Jahren, wenn man sieht, das ist scheitert.
Ich hab's vor die Wand gefahren.
Genau. Ja und ich bin mit dabei.
Es ist ja nicht von alleine gescheitert, sondern wie Merkel saß am Steuer.
Und ein paar andere vorher natürlich auch. Aber das ist doch ein Moment, wo auch so eine ganze Gesellschaft, das ist ja das, was ich so vermisse. Wir sagen Fukushima ist explodiert und Tsunami und so weiter. Das ist ja viel dramatischer. Das ist ja nicht ein Tsunami, sondern das ist so, als hätte man die ganze Mathematik, der sozusagen die zu einem Atomkraftwerk führt, falsch gemacht. Als würde man plötzlich sehen, die ganzen wissenschaftlichen Grundlagen stemmen nicht so. So wirkt es im Augenblick. Und das artikuliert niemand, sondern alle tun noch so. Sie sagt das ja in jeder Talkshow. Immer diesen Satz, in kontrollierten Schritten. Sie tun ja alle so. Das ist die letzte rhetorische Zuflucht, die sie haben. Kontrolle.
Also den Kontrollverlust nicht zugeben.
Genau. Das ist das, was sie immer sagen. Ja, wir machen das deshalb so, weil wir wollen das in kleinen kontrollierten Schritten. Und was ja jeder weiß, das gar nicht der Fall ist.
Aber das hat doch der Schröder sogar schon gebracht. Der hat auch schon gesagt, der macht jetzt die Politik der ruhigen Hand. Und was war das andere, der kleinen Schritte? Das ist doch dasselbe. Aber da gab es keine Krise. Nein, natürlich gab es da Krise. Aber diese gibt es doch immer. Und wenn es die nicht gibt, dann wird sie ja weggelassen.
Der Unterschied ist ein anderer. Nämlich die Sache mit diesem Kontrollverlust. Also dass das nicht eingestehendes Kontrollverlust ist, der nun so evident ist, dass ihn eigentlich niemand mehr wegdiskutieren kann.
Das wäre doch mal interessant, darüber mit Wissenschaftlern zu reden, wenn die plötzlich merken, und so scheint mir die situation, wir haben ein Experiment am Laufen und merken während des Experiments, dass unsere gesamten Grundlagen nicht stimmen. Sie ist ja Wissenschaftlerin. Was sagt denn ein Wissenschaftler? Leute, die dabei waren, erzählen mir, einer der größten Shocks für sie war bei der ersten Finanzkrise, Lehmann, als sie zum ersten Mal, das war für viele, die dabei waren, wo ein Schock merkte, da war sie umringt von all diesen Leuten. Die sind von Lehmann, Bafin, Ackermann, Deutsche Bank.
Und die wussten es auch alle nicht, ne?
Ja, das war ein Moment, das ist wirklich, ich würde das wirklich, das muss man echt hochhängen. Plötzlich stehen sie gerade auch so, eine Frau, die ja aus einem anderen System auch kam und dieses System hat sich unseres ja auch immer als funktionsfähig dargestellt. Plötzlich sehen sie, dass die Ingenieure des Systems nicht mehr wissen, die Maschinen nicht mehr bedienen können.
Also eigentlich ist Fukushima tatsächlich irgendwie die Schablone.
Ja, es ist ein, ich würde sogar noch weitergehen, Fukushima nicht nur mit Tsunami, sondern auch mit gleichzeitigem Fehler in der gesamten Berechnung des physikalischen Prozesses. Das ist ein, und darum, so erkläre ich mir übrigens auch, warum Fukushima, das ist ein Paradigma halt gewesen, da so schnell Handlungsfähigkeit gezeigt werden musste.
Naja, aber ich meine, verstehe, also de facto war Fukushima halt der politische Archetyp für die situation.
Ja, natürlich, Ackermann redete doch schon vorher von Kernschmelzen. Das ist ja ein, das ganze Modell, da steht ja. Und jetzt...
Und deswegen mussten sie Handlung, und da waren die Atomkraftwerke abschalten, war halt der Preis dafür, dass Handlungsfähigkeit demonstriert wurde.
Und ich kann jetzt nur, wenn ich das einen Satz dazu noch sagen darf, und das will ich mich gar nicht hier irgendwie meiner... Ich glaube, es gibt viel weniger Geheimnisse in der Politik, als man glaubt, das meiste ist öffentlich. Aber ich habe die letzten zwei Jahre dafür benutzt, jedem, dem ich habhaft werden konnte, aus diesem Personal zu fragen, was geht eigentlich vor und was wird geschehen. Und ich kann hier zu Protokoll geben, dass es niemand beantworten kann. Und ich hab, glaube ich, mit allen geredet.
Also was uns jetzt ein bisschen zu dieser Frage bringt, was sind dann eigentlich die handlungsmotivationen von Politikern?
Einen Aspekt möchte ich noch ansprechen. Also ich habe diverse Freunde und Kollegen in anderen EU-Ländern und eine Sache, die ich immer wieder von ihnen höre, ist, dass deren Politik sich fast vollständig an der Deutschen orientiert. Und das geht bis in Details, wie teuer jetzt eine Art Neimittel werden darf. Die warten ab, bis die deutschen Preis festlegen und machen das dann. Und aus dem Winkel betrachtet, erscheint mir auch plötzlich, das als ein sehr hohes Gut, zumindest den Anschein zu wahren, als wisse man, was man tue. Und in kleinen Schritten Aktivismus zu machen, weil es geht gar nicht mal nur um das eigene Volk, die diese Einsicht nicht haben darf, dass im Grunde keiner weiß, was gerade passiert, sondern da ist noch die gesamte EU um uns herum, die auch plötzlich Panik kriegen könnte, wenn sie merken, wir wissen schon nicht, was hier los ist.
Wir haben de facto als Deutschland, muss man ja mal so sagen, gerade die Verantwortung für Europa am Hals.
Ja, aber das geht noch weiter, das ist nicht nur eine Platitüde, will ich sagen, sondern es ist tatsächlich so, bis in die Niederung der Verordnungen in den jeweiligen Ländern.
Umso schlimmer ist es ja, dass wir mit diesem Personal gerade in dieser situation sind. Vielleicht ist es ja immer so.
Ja, wahrscheinlich haben das auch frühere Zeiten so empfunden, dass es auch kein gutes Personal war. Wobei ich einen fundamentalen Unterschied zu der Vergangenheit ziehe, selbst zu Lehmann. Was sie da sagen, mit den anderen europäischen Ländern stimmt, glaube ich schon, die wissen ja auch alle, dass wir eigentlich die Kontrolle nicht haben. Aber die pure Macht kann ja Kontrolle sein. Hauptsache, ich habe Macht, und das hat ja Deutschland, dann ist das schon Kontrolle. Was das Neue ist, und das ist etwas, was ich glaube, das finde ich, für mich ist das die, wie soll man das beschreiben, ohne jetzt wieder als Apokalyptiker zu gelten.
Ach, das können Sie bei uns ruhig sagen.
Ist das hier auf dem Sender erlaubt?
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Wir können Sie gerne so viel apokalypten, wie Sie möchten.
Okay, es ist vor allem das, wenn das passiert, kann man datieren, die Frage ist doch immer, warum haben die nicht, das wäre jetzt ja gleich bei Griechenland gesagt. Das geht so nicht, das ist ja die Frage, warum haben die so lange gewartet? Und dann ist ja die Antwort, wir können nicht mehr offen reden, weil wir Finanzmärkte beeinflussen. Wir müssen eigentlich immer um die Ecke denken und das sagen die ja auch wirklich, das ist wirklich der Satz. Weiter gedacht, und dem Satz würden die noch nicht mal widersprechen, heißt es, wir müssen die Unwahrheit sagen, um nicht zu sagen, lügen, weil wir nicht die Finanzmärkte, also das, was sie erwarten, was Finanzmärkte tun könnten, zu beeinflussen. Die Erwartung, eine Erwartung, eine Erwartung. Das ist die Regel jetzt in der ökonomischen und politischen diskussion seit zwei Jahren. Das heißt, es ist wirklich Lüge. Und zwar moralisch legitimiert damit, dass man sagt, ja, wir wollen ja nicht, dass irgendwelche Investmentbanker jetzt damit wieder ein Spiel beginnen. Aber faktisch ist es eine völlig unhaltbare situation.
Wir haben ja eine Vorsendung mit einem Spekulanten gemacht. Oder ich sage mal Trader. Und der hat gesagt, ach wissen die, das haben wir doch alle schon eingepreist. Das heißt, dieses Argument ist...
Das hat er gesagt, zu allem, ne?
Dieses Argument ist noch nicht mal stichhaltig. Das ist die griechische Tragödie an der situation. Es ist noch nicht mal stichhaltig, weil die Märkte das schon längst vorhergesehen haben und es schon eingepreist haben.
Und vor allen Dingen, das ist doch der Unterschied zwischen Reden und Machen und Politik. Ja, da muss man halt, wenn man ein Faktum schafft und nicht nur von Erwartungen ausgeht, dann wird man halt sehen, was passiert. Und das Politik jetzt zeigt, dass sie das nicht kann, sondern so in diesem unwahrhaftigen Gerede bei sich selber bleibt. Das ist ein wirkliches Drama. Die hätten wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal den Bundestag richtig informiert über alles das, wenn sie nicht gezwungen worden wären, weil sie einfach mit dem Argument, was ja vielleicht auch nur ein Scheinargument ist, wir beeinflussen irgendwelche Märkte. Und ich glaube, darüber wird man, wenn dieser ganze Pulverdampf verzogen ist, wird man noch ganz schön nachdenken, was hier passiert ist.
Aber aus Ihrer Erfahrung mit diesen Menschen, ich habe ja noch ein bisschen Erfahrung mit Politikern, also sie wahrscheinlich noch sehr viel mehr. Was motiviert die denn? Also was treibt die denn zum Handeln? Also die Politiker?
Ich möchte ja jetzt nicht hier so Bashing und so weiter. Da gibt es ja auch jeder, es ist natürlich anders. Ich kann Folgendes sagen, was für mich, was ich gelernt habe. Und es ist noch gar nicht so lange her, dass ich es gelernt habe. Und ich bin ja nicht politischer Journalist. Ich sehe das immer aus so einer kulturellen Perspektive. Und ich hatte immer eine Sache völlig verinnerlicht. Die war so, dass ich dachte, ein Politiker will irgendwie gut dastehen vor der Geschichte. Das war mein Ausgangspunkt. Der will nicht in sechs Jahren oder in zehn Jahren dastehen als der, der wirklich hier die große Katastrophe. Und das revidiere ich jetzt. Und zwar deshalb, weil ich sehe, dass es eben gar nicht passiert. Es wird nie jemand verantwortlich gemacht. Wer wird verantwortlich gemacht für den Zustand der Rente? Da wissen wir, das hätte man in den 90er Jahren bereits demografisch. Das wäre die Regierung Kohl. Wer ist verantwortlich für den Maastricht-Vertrag? Wer hat die falschen Anreize gesetzt? Es wird nie jemand verantwortlich. Im Gegenteil, die Leute treten alle in Talkshows auf und sind Experten. Selbst der große Helmut Schmidt, der uns einiges eingebrockt hat an Staatsverschulung. Als ich das revidierte, also mir klarmachte, nein, das ist eben nicht so. Sondern es geht mehr um die Echtzeit als um irgendwie das Urteil der Geschichte. Das ist wie das Urteil des jüngsten Gerichts. Da glaube ich, ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, was die antreibt im Einzelnen. Aber ich glaube, dass das das Gefährlichste ist in Politik. Dass das verloren gegangen ist.
Also früher dachte man doch eigentlich, dass so ein Politiker, wenn man jetzt mal wieder ins alte Rom guckt zum Beispiel, da war es doch so, dass so ein Politiker im Wesentlichen irgendwann angefangen hat, für die Nachwelt zu arbeiten. Selbst amerikanische Präsidenten haben ja meistens irgendwie den zweiten Teil ihrer zweiten Amtszeit damit verbracht, sich noch mal als Wohltäter hinzustellen, um der Nachwelt zu... Ich meine selbst Reagan, ist ja tatsächlich, kann man sagen, in den Augen vieler Amerikaner immer noch der Totale hält. Wenn man sich die Details anguckt...
Ja, da gibt es keinen rationalen... Aber der Clinton hat lustigerweise, da gibt es ein sehr schönes Beispiel, der Clinton hat ein paar völlig unhaltbare Umweltschutzgesetze in den letzten Tagen seiner Amtszeit gemacht, von denen er genau wusste, dass sie sofort revidiert werden von den Republikanern. Also von dieser Art von Gesetzgebnissen.
Aber gibt es das bei deutschen Politikern nicht mehr? Also arbeiten die nicht mehr für ihr Ansehen in der Nachwelt?
Also man kann sowas ja nicht verallgemeinern. Aber Kohle hat ganz viel Energie darauf noch gelegt. Der war ja auch sehr historisch. Die Frage ist ja immer, wenn man so ein bisschen die moderne kommunikation durchschaut, ist ja auch immer die Frage, was ist denn diese Nachwelt? Also ich glaube, dass sich das wirklich geändert hat. Ist das Wikipedia oder ist das der Google-Treffer Nummer 175, wo steht, er hat eine tolle Bundestagsrede gehalten? Das ist wirklich immer die Frage. Ist die Nachwelt die Nachwelt im Jahre 2020 oder die im Jahr 2030? Ich glaube, hier ist eine wirkliche Relativierung. Hat sie eingesetzt und die merken auch, dass die Belohnung gar nicht so groß ist, wie sie dachten. Ich glaube, das sind ganz, ganz...
Liegt es aber vielleicht auch an dieser Kollektivierung. Also ich meine, wir haben ja gesagt, dass wir ja offensichtlich aus unserer Geschichte heraus mehr kollektive, langsame Entscheidungen, Konsensprozesse bevorzugen in der Politik und weniger die Verdienste einzelner Politiker. Das heißt also, ist da nicht vielleicht so, dass genau diese Herausbildung dieser Prozesse, die fraktion hat entschieden und nicht irgendwie der Einpeitscher hat irgendwie das durchgebracht und kann sich dafür den Orden an die Brust helfen, keine Ahnung, diesen Dienens durchgebracht zu haben?
Nein, der Kanzler ist ja viel stärker geworden als in der Vergangenheit, muss man wirklich sagen. Das ist gerade das, das sehen Sie bei der Merkel ganz deutlich. Aber die ist doch in der fraktion, innerhalb der fraktion. Also das ist, schauen Sie sich mal an, wie der Helmut Schmidt immer vorgeführt wurde oder der wie die Brandt vorgeführt wurde.
Ja, stimmt, vor der fraktion, ja.
Das war ja unglaublich. Aber wenn Sie mal den Begriff Nachwelt übersetzen, in einen ökonomischen Begriff, dann hat man eigentlich die Antwort ganz schnell und dann sieht man die Gesellschaft sehr deutlich. Nachwelt könnte man auch genau bestimmen in diese ganzen Fragen der Staatsverschuldung. Das ist doch genau der Punkt. Was muten wir unser Nachkommen zu? Welche Schulden? Welche Belastungen und so weiter? Und die Antwort der Gesellschaft, der Politik lautete, für die Gegenwart alles, die Nachwelt ist egal. Da hat man es ja richtig in Zahlen greifen. Und dann gab es ein paar, das muss man wirklich sagen, die Grünen an der Spitze, die erst mal über die Ökologie dieses Nachweltthema ganz neu gestellt haben. Wollen wir wirklich generationenversorgung...
Für den Planeten nur gebraucht, ja.
Genau, damit fing das an. Das war im Grunde ein progressiver Prozess. Während aber die reale Politik, man muss wirklich nur Staatsverschuldung sagen. Für uns ist Nachwelt, so wie sie sich darstellt, eine Nachwelt, die für uns bezahlt. Das ist das, was es ist und das finde ich in der Politik. Ich kann eine Geschichte, eine kurze Geschichte erzählen, die sich mir wahnsinnig eingeprägt hat. Und das ist eben Alte Bundesrepublik, so bin ich groß geworden. Ich hatte mal als Journalist, noch am Anfang der 90er-Jahre war ich mal dabei als Berichterstatter bei dem Treffen von Mitterrand, Helmut Kohl und Ernst Jünger, diesem Schriftsteller in Wilflingen, bei dem Zuhause. In dem Raum befanden sich dann, das war wirklich toll, nur Mitterrand, Kohl, Jünger und ich und Übersetzer. Und dann fingen Mitterrand und Jünger an, völlig apokalyptisch zu reden. Was wird im 21. Jahrhundert passieren? Es war am 20. Juli 1993, weiß ich heute noch, weil es der 20. Juli war. Und dann fing Jünger an, der ja auch in Apokalyptik, es wird unangenehm werden, die Menschen werden die Technik nicht und die Griff bekommen, die Titanen und so weiter. Mitterrand fing an aus dem Stehgreif zu sagen, das war auch irre, aus dem Stehgreif wirklich, wie oft welche Länder oder welche Reiche im 20. Jahrhundert zusammengebrochen waren. Also Russland so und so oft. Es war auch interessant zu sehen, dass es eben nicht nur einmal war, es war richtig apokalyptisch. Und Kohl saß mit einer kleinen Espresso-Tasse gegenüber und ich beobachtete ihn genau und ich sah, dass ihm total mulmig wurde bei diesem Gespräch. Und dann hielt er es nicht mehr aus und jetzt haben sie die Bundesrepublik und unterbrach das Gespräch und brüllte so rein, ich bin ganz optimistisch. Und dann war das Gespräch zu Ende mit diesem Satz. Da haben sie so genau diese, da haben sie den Franzosen und diesen Schriftstellern mit diesem ganzen Sensibilität auch für Krisen und da haben sie dieses andere, dieses urbundesrepublikanische Trampel, aber auch so im Sinne von, wir lassen uns unsere Laune nicht färben. Und das ist ein Kennzeichen der alten Republik gewesen und ich glaube, das ist total weg. Das ist jetzt, wir sind jetzt in dieser Übergangsphase, wo man noch nicht weiß, können wir in dieser Obkrise noch immer so weiter machen wie bisher oder nicht, aber diese koaltsche optimistische Grundhaltung gegenüber den Dingen, Optimismus war ja nur ein Kampfbegriff, das ist vorbei.
Aber das heißt, wenn wir das mal zusammenfassen, so ein Politiker interessiert sich, also wir verallgemeinern jetzt mal wieder unzulässig, aber sonst kann man ja nicht reden, so ein Politiker interessiert sich nicht mehr so sehr für die Nachwelt. Wie gesagt, meine Theorie ist unter anderem, weil er individuell weniger wichtig geworden ist.
Na überhaupt noch nie ist doch der Punkt, oder? Dass sie sich überhaupt noch nie wirklich außer ein Ausnahmeverhältnis für die Nachwelt interessiert haben.
Nee, das würde ich nicht sagen. Nee, das war früher schon anders. Also spätestens die Grünen sind ja mit dem, wir kümmern uns um die Nachwelt wieder.
Das meine ich mit der Ausnahme.
Aber das ist der Standardmodus.
Das war ja auch schlimm. Hitler hat sich leider viel zu sehr für die Nachwelt interessiert.
Und auch die SPD, also hier Wehner und Co. Total. Und dieses ganze Konzept der sozialen Marktwirtschaft ist ja eben auf die Ewigkeit angelegt. Also dieser Ewigkeitsanspruch von politischem Konzept und ergonomischem System, der dann von den Neokonserts zerbrochen wurde.
Ich glaube, die kriegen kein Benefit, wenn sie heute an die Nachwelt denken.
Genau, aber andersrum heißt es aber auch, dass sie nicht erwarten, dass sie irgendjemand zur Verantwortung zieht. Also dass halt niemand hinkommt und sagt, okay, dafür, dass ihr gerade Europa irgendwie so tief in den Sumpf geritten habt, geht es jetzt einfach mal irgendwie gerade vor irgendein Gericht.
Da gibt es ja auch keine Präzedenzfälle für.
Naja, ich meine, es gibt halt schon Präzedenzfälle. Wir haben schon ein paar Diktatoren, die vor Gericht gegangen sind.
Naja, Diktator ist ja noch was anderes als der Gutachter, der halt einen Fehler gemacht hat.
Die Frage ist ja schon durchaus interessant. Wir haben jetzt ja diesen Präzedenzfall, dass wir ein internationales Strafgerichtshof haben, die zumindest in wirklich extremen Fällen auch mal irgendwelche Diktatoren vor Gericht stellen. Natürlich kann man sagen, ein Politiker kann keine Politik machen, wenn er erwarten muss, dass er irgendwann zur Verantwortung zu wird. Aber vielleicht, wenn wir uns mal das Ausmaß des Schadens angucken, was wir gerade haben, wäre es eben tatsächlich an der Zeit zu sagen, dass es halt irgendeine Art von, zumindest moralischer Verurteilungsinstanz geben muss.
Aber das mit dem Gerichtshof geht mir zu weit.
Klar, deswegen sage ich moralischer Verurteilungsinstanz.
Es gibt ja ein Punkt, unserer Gesellschaft, was am besten funktioniert, das ist moralische, also die Tabuisierung, dass man sagt, dieser Mensch ist kein Gesprächspartner mehr, weil der hat echt hier uns in den Schlamassel reingeritten und so. Das ist etwas, was die auch natürlich stört. Nehmen Sie jetzt, ich rede jetzt wirklich nicht vom Staatsgerichtshof, aber nehmen Sie jetzt die ENBW-Sache in Baden-Württemberg. Das ist natürlich ein Skandal, sondern der Gleichen. Und Mappus müsste sich dafür rechtfertigen. Aber sie werden natürlich niemals ein Gesamtsystem. Und ich will das auch mal sagen, ich glaube, dass diese Leute wirklich, also ich würde nicht hier in das Horn blasen, das sind verantwortungslose Leute, die Merkel und all diese Leute. Das ist gar nicht der Punkt. Die sind in einem Konflikt zwischen dieser Machterhalt, auch diesem Gefühl, wenn wir weg sind, dann wird es noch schlimmer. Die sind aber nicht jetzt irgendwelche, die meinen es schon, die denken schon, dass sie das Beste geben, was sie geben können.
Das zweifle ich auch gar nicht.
Das bezahlt tatsächlich auch nicht. Also muss ich ja sagen, die Politiker, die ich getroffen habe, bei denen hatte ich zumindest auch immer das Gefühl, dass sie nach dem Machterhalt, was ihre primäre motivation ist, durchaus dann manchmal eben doch noch ans Land denken. Das gibt es halt schon noch.
Das stimmt auch. Sie sagen, aber wir sind ja auch noch da, die Wähler.
Da haben wir doch noch Optimismus in der Sendung.
Wir sind in der Mitte der Sendung.
Wir sind doch diejenigen, die den Benefit verteilen. Und wir sind diejenigen, die anerkennen, ob ein Politiker für 20 Jahre denkt oder nur für zwei Monate. Und da kann man ja sehen, wie die Leute entscheiden. Als Steinbrück seine Sache sagt.
Aber das letzte Mal, als jemand sagte, wir denken jetzt mal langfristig, war es irgendwie der Rentenbetrug. Das letzte Mal, als jemand gesagt hat, wir müssen jetzt mal richtig langfristig denken, kam dabei irgendwie diese Riesenerenten raus mit den irgendwie dazugehörigen irgendwie Umschaufelungen von irgendwie noch mehr Geld von unten nach oben.
Lustigerweise würde ich auch nicht übereinstimmen, dass niemand der Schuldige ist, rückblickend für diese die Rentenproblematik. Denn wenn man so, wenn die Presse mal jemand braucht, dann ist es immer der Blüm, weil der sich hingestellt hat. Und gesagt hat, eure Renten sind sicher. Und der wird dann immer aus dem Keller geholt, wenn wir jetzt mal einen Schuldigen brauchen, der diese ganze Rentenproblematik angeht.
Also was die Rentenproblematik angeht, glaube ich, dass die Schuldigen die Familienpolitik der Regierung kohl ist, soweit man so was überhaupt so sagen kann. Weil es hatte ja sehr viel schon mit Dingen der 70er Jahre zu tun. Hätte man damals die Leute darauf vorbereitet und auch diese ganze Frage Vereinbarkeit von Familien, damals war ja noch diese Vorbild, diese Kernfamilie und so, hätte sich vielleicht schon viel geändert. Aber ich möchte noch einen Punkt ansprechen, weil wir ja, also muss man auch nochmal betonen, dass ich auch genau wie Frank Rieger wirklich glaube, also die Politiker, die ich kenne, sind wirklich, das kommt immer gut an, wenn man sagt, sind alle Glauben an nichts? Nein, die glauben schon alle an was und sie bemühen sich schon auch. Aber die neue situation, in der wir uns befinden, die Bundesrepublik Deutschland, unsere generation, unsere Eltern, Großeltern, Urgroßeltern, kennen nur gebrochene Lebensläufe. Also ist immer was passiert. Krise, inflation, Krieg. Und in Geschichtsbüchern lernen wir das. Der Unterschied zu all diesen Dingen in der Vergangenheit ist, dass alle Krisen, die bisher passiert sind, immer von jungen Gesellschaften erlebt worden sind. Sie haben die Mehrheit...
Also die jungen sind demografisch...
Demografisch jung. Das heißt, die Mehrheit der Gesellschaft, selbst wenn sie im Krieg ganze Jahrgänge kaputtgegangen sind, getötet worden, die Mehrheit der Gesellschaft hatte immer noch das subjektive Gefühl, ich habe noch ganz viel Zeit nach dieser Krise, das zu reparieren. Was ein ganz großer Unterschied ist, wenn wir heute, wenn wir diese Krise bekommen, ich glaube, sie beginnt in Kurz-Kürze mit inflation und ähnlichem, die Mehrheit eben schon älter ist, älter als 45 und 50 und nicht mehr das Gefühl hat, ich habe noch subjektiv viel Zeit, ich kann mein Leben noch reparieren. Das wird das eigentliche Problem sein, dass wir eine ganze, quantitativ, wahrscheinlich sogar die größte Gruppe der Bevölkerung haben, die denkt, ich habe nicht mehr genug Zeit. Selbst nach dem Zweiten Weltkrieg war schon in kurzer Zeit demografisch so, dass sie eine mehr oder minder junge Gesellschaft hatten, die sagte, okay, ich bin jetzt 25 oder 30, genau. Jetzt haben wir statistisch 49- bis 55-Jährige und ein Drittel über 60-Jährige, wenn die Krise kommt. Und da sehe ich, dass eigentlich irre was passiert.
Sie hatten doch so eine Studie, die Sie da mal erwähnt haben, die aussagt, genau erzählen Sie doch mal.
Das ist die, Sie meinen die von Max-Planck-Institut? Das ist auch gegen diese ganze Medien-Augenwischerei. Es wird überall behauptet, Ursula von der Leyen sagt das eben auch nochmal in einer Sendung, niemals waren die Alten so solidarisch mit den Jungen wie heute. Das stimmt so nicht. Diese Studie zeigt, das hängt einzig von der Leyen davon ab, ob diese Alten noch Kinder oder Enkelkinder haben. Wenn das signifikant nicht mehr der Fall ist, sinken die Zustimmungsraten, zum Beispiel bei der Frage, soll es keine Studiengebühren geben? Oder soll BAföG erhöht werden? Oder sollen jungen Familien geholfen werden? Um bis zu 80 Prozent. Das heißt, der Zeithorizont einer alternden Gesellschaft verengt sich, vor allen Dingen dann, wenn das auch größt... Also nicht notwendigerweise, wenn niemand was unterstellen, aber das sieht man in vielen, verengt sich immer mehr, sodass am Ende eben nur noch übrig bleiben 15 bis 20 Jahre, die ich noch lebe und alles anderes mir egal. Wenn das passiert, zusammen mit der Krise und die ja auch noch alle wählen, das kommt ja hinzu, das sind ja die Mehrheit der Wähler, also die... Dann kriegen wir hier echt ein Problem. Und wer das gering schätzt oder verhöhnt oder so, erkennt nicht die Dynamik demografischer Prozesse oder sowas. Das ist doch klar, wenn ich jetzt 70 bin oder die Mehrheit der Gesellschaft ist älter als 50 und jetzt kommt ein Projekt, eine richtige vision. Wir reißen uns jetzt zusammen und in 40 Jahren oder in 30 Jahren geht es der Jugend wieder gut und wir haben wieder eine... Wer macht da noch mit?
Wir haben eine Perspektive. Also das interessante daran finde ich ja auch, wenn wir jetzt sagen, der Zeithorizont ist, sagen wir, 15 Jahre oder lassen wir es 20 sein. Der Horizont, über den ich entscheide, der muss ja noch mal signifikant kürzer als das sein, denn ich will ja auch selber noch einen Vorteil daraus ziehen. Das heißt, es müssen eher so 10 Jahre sein, in denen ein effektiver Gewinn zu machen ist. Und wenn wir jetzt so eine Krise haben, wie die Europakrise, die in 10 Jahren eben nicht zu machen ist, dann zeichnet sich ab, dass es da einfach auch keine Lösung geben wird.
Naja, das ist die Frage. Meine Theorie gerade zu diesem, wir nehmen jetzt mal noch eine billion, noch zwei oder so auf, ist ja, dass es halt einfach auf eine Währungsreform zulaufen muss. Also dass es halt einfach keine andere Möglichkeit gibt, als halt einfach zu sagen, wir müssen halt irgendwie diese Währung halbieren, die Schulden halbieren, irgendeine Art von Möglichkeit finden, diesen Berg halt einfach weg zu radieren. Und interessanterweise, wenn man sich halt die Struktur anguckt, wenn jetzt anfangen, tatsächlich das Geld nicht mehr durch Leihen bei den Banken zu drucken, sondern eben durch direktes Drucken über die EZB, dann können sie es tatsächlich tun. Weil dann bricht nicht das ganze System zusammen, weil das Geld von irgendjemand geborgt ist, sondern es ist halt nur gedrucktes Geld.
Naja, das ist auch jetzt schon so, nur dass halt die Banken die Profite abgreifen dürfen.
Ja, naja, nee, aber der Punkt ist halt, wenn du jetzt eine Währungsreform machen würdest, eine große, und sagen würdest, du herbierst halt z.B. alles. Oder du invalidierst bestimmte Mengen an Krediten z.B. oder so. Dann hätte das halt irgendwie massive Aftershocks. Also da würde halt eine Menge passieren an Sachen, dass plötzlich, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Rentenfunks nicht mehr funktionieren und sowas. Wenn aber der größte Teil des Geldes sowieso irgendwie EZB gedruckt, EZB ausgegeben und wieder...
Dann kannst du die einfach wegstreichen.
Und ich glaube, dass wir sowas sehen werden. Also dass es halt eine Notwendigkeit geben wird, weil alles was jetzt passiert zu sagen, die Staaten müssen mehr sparen, die haben zu viel Geld ausgegeben. Also diese ganze Rhetorik, die gerade passiert, die nicht sagt, wo das Geld hingegangen ist, nämlich zum größten Teil zu den Banken, das kann nur noch eine Übergangsphase sein. Also so ein gewisses Geplänkel. Das heißt, dass wir dann schon dahin kommen, dass es halt radikale Schnitte geben wird. Die möglicherweise auch große Teile der Bevölkerung benachteiligen, weil die Frage nach so einer Krise ist ja immer, wer es profitiert hinterher davon.
Ganz genau.
Also wer sozusagen, wer setzt die Regeln, wie es danach aussieht. Und da sind zum Beispiel auch die Währungsreformen am Anfang der Bundesrepublik interessant. Da gibt es ja echte Abgründe. Du erinnerst dich noch an diese Geschichte mit diesen Hypotheken, wo dann halt eine Menge Leute halt einfach benachteiligt waren. Deswegen war sie halt plötzlich auf Hypotheken, die nicht eigentlich abgewertet wurden und so. Und also so eine Sache, die, also diese, also wenn es daran geht, dass so eine radikale Schnitte passieren, dann ist allerhöchste Aufmerksamkeit in Detail notwendig. Also so ganz brutal, dass die Presse auch richtig gefordert, dass in dem Umblick muss man wirklich hingucken. Und selbst wenn es dann 600-seitige Verträge sind, dann muss man die mit der Lupe lesen, weil da hängt es dann wirklich davon ab, wie die Zukunft aussieht. Weil da sitzen dann nämlich die Goldman Sachs und diese anderen Leute dieser Welt, die dann halt versuchen, halt diese Entscheidung zu beeinflussen. Und mit dem politischen Personal, also der Kompetenz, diesem Kontrollverlust, der da ist, kann es dann halt nur noch schlimmer werden. Also dann wird es nach der Krise noch schlimmer als vor der Krise.
Also eine Sache finde ich schon noch wichtig an der Stelle, nämlich, dass wenn wir sagen, das Geld geht zu den Banken, dann meinen wir nicht zu den Banken, sondern die zahlen sich das als Bonus aus.
Zu den Bankherren, ja.
Ja, zu den Bankern, nicht zu den Banken. Und das ist eine wichtige Sache, denn die ursprüngliche Begründung war ja, das Geld soll zu den Banken fließen, denn die verleihen das ja dann. Das war ja die Idee dahinter. Und genau das passiert ja nicht, sondern die zahlen sich das als Bonus aus. Aber also diese 1%, 99% Sache hinter Occupy, Wall Street und Occupy, whatever, das ist schon so. Ja, also ein Wort, was Frank und ich gerne mal in diskussionen verwenden, ist die Automatisierungsdividende. Wir haben halt viel Geld dafür ausgegeben über die Jahre, dass wir Maschinen bauen, die uns die Arbeit abnehmen. Und die Idee war, dass die Leute dann weniger arbeiten müssen. So haben wir das ja verkauft. Und heute keine Sau arbeitet weniger, sondern die arbeiten genauso viel.
Oder gar nicht.
Oder halt gar nicht, genau.
Oder eben auch, oder Feierabend mittlerweile dank E-Mail und all dem anderen ständig erreichbar.
Ja, und die Gewinne sind eben nicht ausgezahlt worden an die Bevölkerung, sondern die haben das 1% hat die mitgenommen.
Aber ich bin kein Ökonom, aber ich würde es gerne noch mal von der anderen Seite sagen, damit man auch versteht, also warum ich auch glaube, dass es unabhängig von Ökonomie eine viel, viel größere Krise ist, als wir denken, wenn es jetzt nur darum ginge, irgendwie den Euro wieder zu stabilisieren und auch einen Währungsschnitt zu machen, das wäre ja noch alles, okay, das sind technische Prozesse, vielleicht geht... Ich glaube, es ist viel mehr passiert. Ich will das an einem einzigen Begriff mal deuten, was wir erleben und wir alle aber mit noch viel zu gebremster Empörung hinnehmen. Aber sie kommt. Ist zum Beispiel ein Mantra unserer gesamten Systems, ist der Begriff Leistung. Leistung heißt, ich tue etwas, am Ende geht es der Gesellschaft gut, meinem Unternehmen gut, dem Staat gut, dem Einzelnen gut. Das ist der Begriff der Leistung. Wir erleben unter, jetzt muss man sagen, unter einer, gerade jetzt zum Ende, auch einer konservativ-liberalen, aber es hat vorher schon begonnen, das ist die Zerstörung eines wirklichen religionsinhalts dieser Gesellschaft. Das ist nicht mehr aufrechtzuerhalten. Der Satz von Paul Krugman, eine Gesellschaft, in der der bestbezahlte Hedgefondsmanager im Jahr so viel verdient wie alle Lehrer des Bundesstaats New York zusammen in einem Jahr, hat dieses, da gibt es dieses Prinzip nicht mehr. Das heißt, das ist ein Prinzip, an das wir noch glauben, wir erleben, dass sämtliche, in Anführungszeichen Leistungsträger, also alle diese, ob das jetzt Krankenschwestern sind, ich will das jetzt, ob das Mittelständler sind, das sind ja alle diejenigen, die erleben, Menschen, die zum Beispiel, das ist ja auch so ein Wahnsinn, Menschen, die jetzt zum Beispiel das ernst nehmen und für ihre Alter sparen oder so. Das sind ja auch alle. Dieser Begriff, der ist wirklich, das ist wie ein Virus, der ist total zerstört. Und ich glaube, dass das, da das das Leistungsethos dieser Gesellschaft selber betrifft, dass das viel schlimmer sein wird. Solche Phänomene ist ja nur eines, als diese ganze Währungssache. Die Krise ist viel tiefer. Wer glaubt, wer sieht sich noch anerkannt? Wer sieht sich noch sozusagen in relation zu anderen bezahlt? Dazu zählt auch diese Automatisierungs-Dividende. Jetzt sehen wir sogar, dass die, die erkennbar eine negative Leistung bringen, eine zerstörerische Leistung, siehe Hedgefonds-Manager oder auch andere, muss ich nur die nennen, auch noch ein Benefit davon haben. Das ist mehr als... Früher wäre jetzt eine revolution ausgebrochen, da sind sich glaube ich alle einig, muss man so sagen. Jetzt hatten wir die als historische Erfahrung schon gehabt und haben auch gesehen, dass das so nicht funktioniert. Die wird sich jetzt vielleicht auch dank Internet andere Bahnen brechen. Ich kann nicht vorher sagen, in welche. Ich glaube nur, also da bin ich jetzt echt auch mal Apokalyptiker. Ich glaube, die Zäsur ist viel, viel größer als wir denken. Niemand geht zu denen zurück. Ich habe heute telefoniert mit jemanden, das glaubt kein Mensch. Das wäre so vor 20 Jahren der Inbegriff des mittelständischen Unternehmers, ja, verantwortlich auch für viele andere. Der hat mir, als ich mit ihm redete, da hätte ich auch mit Lenin reden können. Das ist im Sinne auch dieser Empörung über den Verrat, so muss ich das zusammenfassen, einer Klasse, so hätte man das früher gesagt, heute ist es eine Gesellschaftsschicht, an einer Gesamtgesellschaft. Das ist das, was wir erleben. Noch haben wir die Substanz, aber die geht so was von schnell weg, diese Substanz. Da soll sich doch niemand was vormachen. Menschen, die ihr Leben lang gearbeitet haben, gespart haben und da noch 30 Jahre weiterleben. Wie sollen die finanzieren? Gesundheitskosten. Sie haben auch nichts mal zu vererben. Das ist ja alles erkennbar, dass das der Weg ist. Und darum denke ich, dass wir in diesem Jahrzehnt noch diese gesellschaftlichen Widersprüche total aufbrechen werden. Und ich sehe aber niemanden, der im Augenblick darauf eine Antwort hat.
Na die spannende Frage ist ja, was passiert denn dann? Und also da haben wir schon eine Weile darüber diskutiert.
Wir haben auch eine Sendung gemacht, wo wir gesagt haben, wo wir gesagt haben, wir sollten versuchen, in unserem Bekanntenkreis jeweils so einen Zirkel zu gründen, wo wir aus den verschiedenen Gebieten, die man so braucht, halt jemanden hat, der sich auskennt. Also ich sag mal, einer der weiß, wie man Lebensmittel anbaut, einer der weiß, wie man ein Haus isoliert.
Super Idee.
Und dass man halt guckt, dass man für Notfälle, also jetzt nicht vorbereitet ist, aber dass man zumindest so die groben wichtigen Überlebenssachen einfach mal klären kann. Und dass man auch dem ein bisschen gelassener entgegensehen kann, als wenn man jetzt völlig der Großstädter ist, der, wenn der Supermarkt geschlossen hat, nix zu essen hat.
Ich möchte gerne noch mal eine Rückbeziehung zum Trojaner machen. Auch warum ich das so wichtig genommen oder was mich daran so betrifft. Bevor diese ganze Trojanerkiste kam, ich kann ja auch immer nur aus meiner Empirie, meinen Gesprächen und so weiter reden, sagte mir jemand, den ich sehr sehr schätze, der in der Politik auch eine Rolle spielte, jetzt aber nicht mehr drinne ist, der immer ganz nüchtern war, der sagte mir, er habe das Gefühl, dass die Leute mit dem Grundgesetz, also auch dem Geschenk des Grundgesetzes und der Verfassung gar nichts mehr verbinden. Also dass das so, diese generation jetzt, dass das so mitge, ist halt da, aber ich erinnere mich auch noch wie in den 70er Jahren, und ich konnte das gar nicht so so richtig glauben, also im Sinne von, dass das ein, dass es die, der Anker ist für alles. Und diese Trojaner-Affäre, auch wie darauf reagiert wurde, ist darum so unglaublich wichtig, weil im Grunde die die Art und Weise, wie ernst man das nimmt, darüber entscheidet, wie groß die Sensibilität für dieses Grundgesetz noch ist. Und für das Geschenk des Grundgesetzes. Was heute der Trojaner ist, kann morgen was ganz anderes sein. Und dieses Gefühl, dass das in institutionen, aber auch bei Einzelnen, gar nicht mehr als eine Errungenschaft wahrgenommen wird, sondern vielleicht sogar als eine Last, aber zumindest als etwas, was man auch gar nicht mehr kennt, das kommt ja auch noch hinzu, das finde ich auch, das finde ich... Da sollten eigentlich diese Trojaner-Debatte, darum ist ja Ull auch so bedenklich, weil er die Chance gar nicht gesehen hat, die sich daraus ergibt, dass man da eine Debatte über unsere Werte führen kann.
Ich meine, das wäre eigentlich das, was ich von Politik erwarten würde. Also zu sagen, okay, gut, wir sind jetzt irgendwie da reingeritten, wir wissen, wo die Probleme liegen, wir müssen möglicherweise halt irgendwie eine ganze Schicht unserer Gesellschaft wahrscheinlich resozialisieren, also denen halt einfach irgendwie Jobs geben oder Rollen in der Gesellschaft zuweisen, die nichts mit Zocken zu tun haben, sondern die halt, sag mal, sinnvoll verwenden. Früher hieß es halt Stasi in die produktion, wahrscheinlich muss es jetzt halt heißen. Keine Ahnung, Hedgefondsmanager in die Altersheime. So, also anders kann ich...
Auf die armen alten Leute.
Ja, naja, Gott, die sollen mal was Sinnvolles tun, ja. Gut, ich meine, diese Studie, die du neulich hattest, mit den Ähnlichkeiten zwischen Psychopathen und Trädern, fand ich auch sehr hübsch. Anyway, der Kern ist doch eigentlich, dass wir sind doch an einer Stelle, die so ein bisschen mich erinnert an so 1990 so ungefähr. Also so ein Punkt, wo allen klar ist, es geht eigentlich eher so 1989, es geht nicht mehr weiter. Es gibt halt irgendwie, also so wie es bisher war, kann es nicht mehr weitergehen. Wir haben keine gute Idee, was jetzt kommen soll.
Das war jetzt in der DDR.
Ja, DDR, was jetzt das nächste sein soll. Zum Glück gibt es dann noch diese Bundesrepublik, die uns sagt, wie wir es machen sollen. Also wir hatten noch so eine Bundesrepublik. Und jetzt sind wir in genau derselben situation, nämlich das alte System ist korrupt, also wir können nicht mehr weiter.
Mit dem ganzen Dampf, aber jetzt haben wir keinen mehr, wo wir uns anhängen können.
Es gibt jetzt halt gerade keine Bundesrepublik mehr. Es gibt halt niemanden auf der Welt, also kein System, wo man sagen kann, machen wir einfach so.
Ja, darum hat es ja die Bundesregierung geschafft. Darüber haben wir uns ja auch schon gestritten. Das finde ich ja, da bin ich ja gar nicht. Darum hat es sie erst geschafft, sozusagen einen Feind vom eigenen Fleischer zu finden und denen, den Leuten, das sind die Banken, wo ich sofort d'accord bin, dass man die Banken angreift, Occupy. Nur, sie hat es ja echt geschafft, zum Aufstand gegen sich selber aufzurufen. Weil die Politik, die wirklich hauptverantwortlich ist, hier gar nicht ins Gesichtsfeld kommt. Also ein paar demonstrationen, die das berücksichtigen, wären hier schon sinnvoller.
Naja, also ich finde ja, dass diese Merkel-Umarmung für Demonstranten und auch diese Schäuble-Umarmung, dass die wahrscheinlich noch damit zu tun hat, dass sie diese Banken irgendwie disziplinieren müssen. Und dass sie denen jetzt sagen müssen, okay, pass mal auf, Jungs.
Ich lass bald meine Kettenhunde los sozusagen.
Tut uns wirklich leid so, wenn ihr nicht wirklich irgendwie demnächst auf einer einsamen Insel wieder aufwachen wollt, dann müssen wir jetzt halt hier mal was tun. Und guckt euch mal die Demonstranten da draußen an.
Noch haben wir Geld, um die Security zu bezahlen.
Noch haben wir das Geld, die Polizisten zu bezahlen, die sie daran hindern, eure Banken zu stürmen. Aber vielleicht ist es ja morgen nicht mehr so, wenn ihr uns dazu zwingt, kein Geld mehr zu haben. So interpretiere ich die Sache. Aus meiner Kenntnis heraus von so Hedgefonds-Leuten, die sind halt wirklich zutiefst amoralisch. Die sind verwundert darüber, dass sie noch weiter zocken dürfen. Die verstehen nicht, warum die Politik sie noch lange nicht deportiert hat.
Ja, eben. Verstehe ich auch nicht.
Das lustige ist doch, dass sie überhaupt kein Problem damit hätten, wenn man ihnen das Geld wegnimmt. Die machen jetzt halt nur die opposition dagegen, weil sie halt gucken wollen, wie weit sie kommen. Aber die wären jetzt nicht irgendwie beleidigt oder würden das Handtuch werfen.
Da steht doch genau die Frage, wieso ist das? Das ist ja nun die Gretchenfrage. Es ist eine Regulierung. Das sagt jetzt jeder, wir dauern seit Lema nicht gegeben hat, obwohl sie versprochen worden ist. Und das ist nun mal das Geschäft der Politik. Ich weiß auch schon, was die dann darauf antworten. Wir können es nicht wegen Amerika. Wir können es nicht wegen der internationalen...
Nein, die haben sich halt abkauft.
Das ist doch ein Wettbewerbsnachteil.
Nee, also ich meine, warum es nicht passiert ist, lässt sich ja anhand z.B. der amerikanischen Regulierungsdebatte eins an nachvollziehen, da ist es so, dass irgendwie jedes einzelne dieser Regelungen, die versucht wurde, da reinzudiskutieren, wurde von den Bankenlobbyisten und den Hedgefondslobbyisten da wieder rausdiskutiert. So, und dann haben wir UK, die mittlerweile so dermaßen von den Banken abbrechbar sind, dass sie nicht mehr handlungsfähig sind, aber Deutschland auch nicht. Ich meine, Deutschland ist in einer situation, wo halt einfach die Politik durchaus in der Lage wäre zu sagen, so na dann halt ohne euch.
Eben, und darum frage ich mich ja, warum die Politik...
Was uns wieder zu der Frage zurückbringt, was ist denn die eigentliche motivation von Politikern?
Warte mal, wir sollten diese eine Studie zitieren, die wir gerade hatten. Da gab es nämlich ein Paper, wo ein paar Grafen-Theoretiker sich angeguckt haben, wer eigentlich...
Wem die Welt gehört.
Wem gehört eigentlich die Welt, was ja eine Frage ist, die uns alle interessiert. Und die haben eine Liste von, wie viel waren es?
50.
50 Firmen gebracht. Und da waren zwei Deutsche dabei. Die Deutsche Bank war, ich glaube, auf Platz 12.
Und dann war noch Axa.
Nee, die Allianz. Axa ist französisch. Und dann war noch die Allianz auf 18 oder so. Und das war alles. Der Rest ist USA und die Briten. Auf Platz 1, spannenderweise, Barclays. Das hab ich ja überhaupt nicht kommen sehen. Ich dachte, das ist von...
Eigentlich muss man dazu sagen, dass diese Studie primär werverwaltet...
Die Daten sind schon älter.
Ich nenn ihn vor allem, wer verwaltet diese Anteile. Also es geht nicht darum...
Na, wer kontrolliert es im Sinne von, wer hat da jetzt, wer kann das Stimmrecht?
Ja, genau. Bei wem ist das Stimmrecht. Aber die Frage, warum lässt die Politik so lange durchgehen und warum passiert da nichts, hat meines Erachtens sehr mit diesen Beziehungsgeflechten zu tun, zwischen Politik und Finanzen. Und eben den Parteispenden zum Beispiel.
Wir haben auf diese... Das würde mich ja auch mal interessieren. Wir haben ja jetzt das Internet. Also ich hab gehört, wir haben das jetzt, ja. Und ich erfinde ja, dass die großen Geheimnisse noch gar nicht gelüftet sind. Also wickelig hin oder her. Aber das wäre jetzt das für mich zum Beispiel die unbeantwortete Frage. Wieso, völlig unbeantwortet. Ich weiß ja genau, was uns gesagt wurde, auch hinter den Türen, was nach Lehmann passieren sollte. Wieso ist es da noch nicht mal im Ansatz versucht worden? Das ist ein Rätsel. Ich kann es mir nicht nur so erklären, dass da Interessen sind, so wie sie eben die linke Theorie sagt. Da muss mehr dahinter sein. Ich habe darauf aber keine Antwort. Vielleicht kriegen wir sie irgendwann mal. Denn auch bei Obama würde ich jetzt nicht ohne weiteres denken, dass Obama nur der Spielball von verschwörerischen kapitalistischen Kräften ist.
Gucken Sie sich doch mal an, wer da in der Regierung sitzt.
Da gibt es Statistiken zu übrigens zu Obama und den Banken. Dem sind zum Großteil seine letzten Wahlkampf-Sachen bezahlt worden von Wall Street. Und die sind alle abgesprungen. Und da geht es um millionenbeträge. Und das ist ja nun so, wir haben ja dieses Thema hier.
Aber ich meine, der Geiter ist ein Goldman Sachs-Mann.
Ja, natürlich. Aber das ist schon tradition in den USA.
Aber der hat die ganze administration voll mit Leuten, die irgendwie...
Die von Goldman Sachs kommen, natürlich.
Und in Deutschland ist das genau dasselbe.
Nein, ich will sagen, sobald Obama so ein bisschen an der Fahne dreht, springen die mit den Wahlkampfspenden ab. Der hat noch nix beschlossen, was irgendwie schädlich wäre für die. Und da sind die schon abgesprungen, obwohl die die gesamte Regierung gekapert haben bei dem. Die Treasury wird komplett von irgendwelchen ex-Goldman Sachs Leuten bestückt.
Also Deutschland ist auch genau dasselbe Spiel. Da haben wir das ganze Finanzministerium, sitzt voll mit Leuten, die sind da on loan aus der Industrie. Wir sind aber nicht... Wir haben nicht mal mehr Experten, die unabhängig sind. Also die Leute, die gerade für Deutschland in diesen Gremien unterwegs sind, um irgendwie diesen ganzen Euro-Kraut zu fangen, sind alles Banker.
Aber wir haben ein System, das ich an der Stelle loben möchte, was mir im Unterricht damals nicht klar geworden ist, warum das eigentlich gut ist, dass bei uns die Wahl, der Wahlkampf vom Steuerzahler getragen wird. Nach der Wahl wird geguckt, wie viel Stimme... Das ist die einzige Möglichkeit, wie man diese Scheiße los wird, diese Erpressbarkeit über Lobbyisten. Aber man hat sie offenbar immer noch ein bisschen bei uns. Und ich frage mich inzwischen, ob das nicht, ob die Erklärung nicht in diesem, die Denken nur noch kurzfristig ist. Ja, denn wenn man mal sieht, was die ganzen Politiker machen, die aus dem aktiven Dienst raus sind, dann sieht man, traditionell landen die in Lottogesellschaften, in irgendwelchen Auffangbehörden, die keine Sau braucht. So sehe ich im Übrigen auch das Expertenzentrum, was sie jetzt zum Trojaner angekündigt haben. Das ist einfach eine Gelegenheit, noch ein paar alte CDU-Abgehalfterte Politiker zu versinken.
Aber sie landen nicht nur in Lottogesellschaften.
Und sie landen in Aufsichtsräten von der Industrie und von den Großbanken.
Das Neue seit der generation Schröder ist ja, dass sie wirklich richtig aktiv noch, das sind ja ganze Staatssekretäre, ganze generationen sind ja in die Firmen gegangen, über die sie vorher entschieden haben. Zum Teil Minister erlaubnisse durchgebaut.
Das ist halt dieses Drehtüding.
Der Fall Clement und so weiter. Wir sind jetzt aber bei einem Teil, der sozusagen, das ist ja eine alte Debatte, die korruption und die ganze Frage von, ich würde trotzdem noch mal sagen, ich glaube, dass eben das Neue ist, dass die Krise an sich so groß ist, dass sie, ich weiß nicht, wie die Linke darauf reagieren wird, dass sie aber auf alle Fälle die alten Bürgerlichen, jetzt meine ich mit Bürgerlichen, meine ich wirklich ernsthaft.
Gutbürgerliche.
Gutbürgerliche, die haben mit Leistung zu tun, die haben damit zu tun, dass niemand den anderen, würde ich wirklich sagen, über Vorteil, das meine ich mit gutbürgerlich, dass etwas nachprüfbar ist, dass es eine gewisse Moral gibt. Die sind wirklich, die liegen am Boden, die sind zerstört und es gibt keine, charismatische oder wie auch immer Figur, die sie auffängt. Jetzt gibt es Leute, die daraus falsche Schlüsse ziehen werden. Und wir werden sehen, ob das passiert. Es ist durchaus möglich, dass das Parteien-System hier eine neue Antwort findet. Die Piraten müssen nicht die einzige Neugründung sein, sondern es kann durchaus sein, dass sich eine Abspaltung vollzieht. Und zwar genau solche, sich deklassiert fühlender bürgerlichen Milieus, die sagen so, jetzt muss das alles nochmal an. Also eher in der rechtspopulistischen Variante weitergehen. Das ist auch noch nicht ausgemacht, dass so etwas nicht passiert. Wir alle, will ich auch mal sagen, erkennen die Berliner Hauptstadtjournalisten. Ich will nichts gegen die sagen, überhaupt nichts. Die sind am Puls der Macht, auch unsere Leute. Und wir kriegen das alles mit im Kaffee Einstein und wo auch immer. Aber ich habe die Vermutung, dass solche Prozesse sich nicht in der Hauptstadt abspielen werden, sondern woanders. Und dass wir die, ich weiß nicht, ob es Herr Henkel sein wird oder ob es Leute aus seinem Umkreis sein wird. Aber das muss man jedenfalls sehr genau beobachten. Vielleicht ist das wirklich jetzt, geht das in die Geschichtsbücher ein, als die große Zäsur der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Nur kenne ich keinen Politiker, der sie zum Thema machen würde. Das ist das, was mich daran so beschäftigt.
Also der wichtige Punkt dabei ist, gerade wenn es um solche Parteien Neugründungen geht, ist, wo das Geld herkommt. Also, weil sie gerade an Herrn Henkel sagten, so und was ich so hörte, in der Industrie, um es mal anonym zu formulieren, war halt schon durchaus eine Bereitschaft, wenn es da sozusagen einer realwirtschaftsorientierten, rechtskonservative Partei gäbe, um Geld posten, die sich keine Sorgen machen.
Wie sind eigentlich die Piraten? Wie ist das eigentlich finanziert gewesen?
Na, die sind komplett ehrenamtlich, ist also reine Basis.
Aber irgendwie muss man doch so einen Wahlkampf finanzieren.
Brauchten sie nicht, hatten sie Internet.
Haben sie ein paar Designen gemacht? Die FDP macht ja sowas durch, bezahlte.
Also die ersten Wahlkämpfe haben sie so gemacht, dass sie eine Wahlkampfanleihe bei ihren Mitgliedern gemacht haben. Das heißt, die haben sich Geld von den Mitgliedern geborgt, um es dann mit der Wahlkampfkostenrückerstattung wieder zurückzuzahlen. Was man da machen kann. Also ich glaube, die größte Spende war 20.000 oder so. Da haben sich noch die Köpfe eingeschlagen, ob sie jetzt Geld von Firmen annehmen. Also da war nicht so viel unterwegs. Aber die Frage, wird es denn so eine neue Gründung geben, am rechten, sozusagen rechts von der CDU, oder aus einem Teil der CDU, oder zwischen rechten Rand der SPD und CDU?
Aber da zweifelt doch niemand wirklich dran, oder?
Naja, die Frage ist ja, was passiert denn dann? Und die müssen ja was komplett Neues machen. Also die werden ja nicht mit den alten Methoden durchkommen. Und ich denke, dass genau diese Frage, was wir schon mal kurz angerissen hatten, diese Echtzeit der Politik, also dass die Politik immer mehr in so ein Echtzeituniversum geht und auch schon früher war, die wird da, glaube ich, eine ganz große Rolle spielen, was wir bei Gutenberg ja auch schon gesehen haben.
Also ich glaube, was passieren wird, was ich auch schon beobachte, ist, wir denken ja immer, die Geschichte kommt so zurück, wie wir sie schon kennen, aber das ist anders. Und der Trailer des Ganzen oder der Flugzeugträger des Ganzen wird, das war ja sogar in den 20er Jahren auch so, wir haben das nur, lesen das immer anders, weil wir dann gesehen haben Antisemitismus und so weiter, das haben wir dann erkannt, aber eigentlich war das ursprünglich auch ökonomisch. Das heißt, es beginnt, die Ökonomie wird der Trailer sein. Sie können mit ökonomischen Argumenten über Griechenland heute so reden, wie man in Deutschland seit 40 oder 50 Jahren nie über ein anderes Land mehr geredet hat. Plötzlich geht das und viele hängen sich daran. Ein Land, in dem wir ja gehaust haben, bekanntlich wie sonst was, plötzlich kann man sagen, sind faul, unfähig und so weiter. Das war eigentlich tabuiert und diese Tatsache, dass man über Ökonomie, wenn jetzt auch noch in Platz Joko, plötzlich Dinge sagen kann, jetzt denken sie an die Europadebatte, an die nationalstaatsdebatte. Henkel ist ja nichts anderes, als im Grunde die Rückkehr. Er sagt zwar Nordeuro, aber das kann man auch als nationalistisches Argument sehen. Und über diese ökonomische Schiene, glaube ich, da muss man auch sehr aufmerksam sein, werden Dinge, die eigentlich für undenkbar schienen, womöglich zurückkommen. Das heißt, es wird keine Partei sein, so etwas, die daherkommt und sagt, Ausländer raus und so, das wird es gar nicht sein.
Also denke mal, ein guter Stück Sarazin wird auch dabei sein.
Ja, aber eben ökonomisch. Der ist ja auch ökonomisch. Das ist ja biologistisch und ökonomisch. Das ist ja etwas, was immer übersehen wird, dass das eine, darum ist es ja auch so bedenklich, darum haben wir es ja auch so attackiert. Der nimmt zwei ganz anscheinend neutrale Strukturen. Das eine ist der biologismus und das andere ist ja die Ökonomie. Diese ganze Gerede von diese nur Gemüsehändler und so weiter und so fort. Und das beides könnte sich, das wirkt dann ja so rational. Das heißt ja nicht, diesen objektiven Anschein. Genau, das heißt ja nicht, oh, diese Leute haben eine religion, die mir nicht gefällt oder sonst was. Sondern das hat dann plötzlich einen total objektiven Anschein. Und diese neue Form des Positivismus ist deshalb so gefährlich, weil, wie wir ja vorhin besprochen haben, die anderen Gewissheiten ja ruiniert sind. Niemand glaubt mehr einem Banker, wenn der jetzt sagt, wenn ich die und die Zinsen sind und das Derivat und diese. Das heißt, hier ist auch ein Bedarf da. Und darum empfehle ich nur jedem genau aufzupassen, wie sich so ein neues, vulgärwissenschaftliches Weltbild womöglich auch parteipolitisch manifestiert. Der Henkel ist dafür schon ein grandioses Beispiel. Und Saracin ist von der anderen Seite das andere Beispiel.
Also, wenn wir mal eine kurze Sache. Die ausländischen Medien sehen das teilweise durchaus so. Also ich hab's am Economist gesehen.
Stratfor.
Und Stratfor, die haben das deutlich auch so formuliert, dass Großdeutschland sich jetzt wieder Sachen rausnimmt, die wir eigentlich aus dem Dritten Reich kennen.
Das ist doch sehr irre, oder?
Und das fand ich interessant, dass ich das bei uns eigentlich nirgendswo gesehen hab. Oder hat das bei uns eigentlich jemand thematisiert?
Eigentlich fast niemand.
Doch Rösler ist schon sehr attackiert worden.
Rösler ist schon sehr attackiert worden.
Ja, aber trotzdem diese, also eher attackiert worden. Aber interessant ist ja, meine Gutes, mit ein paar Leuten aus dem Außenministerium, mit denen ich gelegentlich rede, die da irgendwie ganz kleine Lichter sind, da kommt es schon vor, aber eigentlich mehr im Sinne von, wir haben jetzt die Verantwortung. Also im Sinne nicht dessen, wie groß Deutschland ist. Naja, muss man sagen, macht das Verantwortung. Und wir haben jetzt als Deutschland, kriegen halt die Verantwortung für dieses Imperium Europa. Bekommen wir halt, weil Kraft irgendwie der Struktur der Euro-Verträge, ist es halt so, dass darin angelegt war, dass Deutschland halt irgendwie die Hegemonialmacht in Europa wird. Und wenn jetzt ist es halt so, wir können das halt nicht länger wegdiskutieren, bis dahin war es halt irgendwie.
Wir geben es nur nicht zu.
Klar, also wir geben es halt natürlich nicht öffentlich zu, weil halt irgendwie dann wurden halt alle schreien. Aber de facto ist es halt so und de facto wurde es halt zum Beispiel in Osteuropa auch so empfunden.
Ja, aber ich hatte da so einen Witz gemacht, den wollte ich gerne nochmal anbringen an der Stelle. Es hat mich nämlich daran erinnert, wie Microsoft in Apple investiert hat, als Apple drohte pleite zu gehen und Microsoft den Anschein erheben wollte, als seien sie nicht die Hegemonialmacht aus kartellrechtlichen Gründen an der Stelle. Aber wir haben ein ähnliches Problem. Im Grunde machen wir ja dasselbe. Wir füttern halt Frankreich mit durch und tun immer so, als sei das so ein Duopol, als hätten die Franzosen was zu sagen. Die sind immer mit dabei und wir machen auch immer Zugeständnisse und machen das auch immer öffentlich, dass wir dieses und jenes als Zugeständnis an Frankreich gemacht haben. Ich finde das durchaus vergleichbar. Also man hört ja, dass im Grunde Frankreich eher so ein Sorgenkandidat ist, als ein ruhender Pol in der EU.
Aber das wurde voraussetzendens kontrastiert mit der diskussion, die wir vorher hatten, nämlich der Frage, ist denn da überhaupt Personal, was da zu einer Lage wäre, mit einer strategischen situation so qualifiziert umzugehen? Ich weiß es momentan nicht.
Also wenn sie eine Lösung wollen, aber das ist das eine. Aber das andere ist doch, das haben wir doch jetzt schon beschrieben, es ist, Fall Guttenberg, es ist für eine Gesellschaft manchmal gar nicht nötig, dass da einer eine Lösung wirklich hat. Also wir fragen ja immer nach dem, der es löst.
Oder nach der Idee, die es löst.
Genau, aber es kann auch einer kommen in solchen Momenten, der einfach die entsprechende Rhetorik hat, die entsprechende Charisma hat. Das ist ja diese inkubationszeit, dass das dann manchmal funktioniert. Und plötzlich sagt eine ganze Gesellschaft, die ja auch jetzt nicht, die Gesellschaft besteht ja nicht aus Experten, sondern die sagen, okay, dieser Mensch wird es lösen. Das heißt, die Gefahr, dass es eher populistisch wird, dass man aber damit durchkommt, die halte ich für sehr viel größer, als dass jemand kommt und sagt, also die Chance ist, dass jemand kommt und sagt, ich habe einen als Partei oder so, wir haben hier eine Lösung. Ich würde nur mal anregen, das wäre mal was auch für die Zeitung. Fällt mir nämlich auf, während wir reden, man müsste jetzt mal, wir sind uns doch einig, wir sind doch einig, was so ein Hedgefondsmanager so leistet für die Allgemeinheit, mehr oder weniger, oder nicht leistet, man müsste jetzt einfach nur mal den Begriff Faulheit, den müsste man sich jetzt mal Gesellschaftliche Faulheit. Jetzt mal genau angucken, in den letzten, und zwar von Sarazin bis hin zu Griechenland. Und das dann mal übersetzen, wer eigentlich in dieser Gesellschaft faul ist, ob es nicht derjenige ist, der sein Geld für sich erarbeiten lässt, also das alte Bild und das Geld von unzähligen anderen oder derjenige, der da an seinem Gemüse stand sitzt. Das sind, ich glaube, wir erleben hier so einen Wertewandel, so eine Vorbereitung für die Instrumentalisierung, das kommt mir fast ohrwältsch manchmal vor, von allen in einer Schnelligkeit, in einer Rapidität, wie ich es nie für möglich gehalten habe, hätte vorher, dass man vielleicht solche Studien mal auch journalistisch verstärkt machen sollte. Ich glaube, bei dem Begriff faul hat käme man sehr weit. Ja. Was wie der so Bedeutungswandel, aber auch wie er jetzt schon eingesetzt wird, was er eigentlich...
Als Kampfbegriff.
Genau, als Kampfbegriff. Und wer aber dann wirklich faul ist, im klassischen Sinn. Ja, also ich meine, noch einmal, also dieser von Paul Krugman beschriebene Hedgefondsmanager ist im Vergleich zu dem, was er verdient, natürlich der faulste Mensch der Welt. Ja, was müsste der leisten, um so viel verdienen zu dürfen, wie alle Lehrer des Bundesstaats New York zusammen? Es gibt ein Hebel, das hat einmal der Robert Frank, ein großer Mann, großer Ökonom in Amerika beschrieben, er hat gesagt, irgendwann in den 90er Jahren ist das passiert, da begann etwas, wo wir alle merkten, dass ein Hebel angesetzt hat bei den Bezahlen, bei den Gehältern in den Banken, der durch keine Leistung mehr zu rechtfertigen war. Und das war etwas, heute wissen wir, dass das so war. Aber das muss man sich mal einfach vorstellen. Das sind Leute, die einfach faktisch keine reale Leistung erbringen, aber nach den Kriterien einer Leistungsgesellschaft unendlich bezahlt werden. Das sind, glaube ich, alles so...
Ich meine, das ist auch der Grund für diese Proteste. Also deswegen denke ich auch, dass diese Proteste durchaus irgendwie an die richtige Reise gehen, weil sie halt einfach eben den... Nicht nur dort, sag ich ja. Also diesen grundlegenden Verstoß gegen Normen und Werte, nach denen 99 Prozent der Gesellschaft leben müssen.
Ich glaube, das Problem ist, dass man die nicht angreifen kann, weil es schon die Notfallantwort ist. Die Idee, dass die Banker für ihre spekulationen Geld verdienen, ist ja die reaktion darauf, dass die Globalisierung die Arbeitsplätze aus dem Herstellenden und Handwerkgewerbe ins Ausland getrieben hat. Und dann bleibt einem auch gar nichts mehr übrig. Die Amerikaner waren da relativ schnell dabei und haben sich halt so ein System zurechtgezimmert, dass man eben mit Intellectual Property Geld verdient und dass spekulation plötzlich auch ein Gewerbe ist. Und deswegen kann man es nicht angreifen, weil dann bleibt ja nichts, es ist ja nichts mehr übrig.
Wir sind vielleicht in der Lage, dass wir echt gar nicht mehr wissen. Gut, da gibt es den EZB Tower und so etwas. Aber das sind alles Vorbedingungen von solchen kafkaisen, anonymen Strukturen, in die moderne Gesellschaft hineinkommt, die mich schon wieder an 89 auch ein bisschen erinnern. Wer ist der Adressat? Das ist ja die entscheidende Frage für kommunikation, dass ich weiß, wer ist der Adressat. Und jetzt wüsste ich gerne mal, wer der Adressat ist. Ist das der Herr Merdhoff? Nein, das ist er bestimmt nicht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich wie 89. Da war der Adressat eigentlich auch nicht Honiger. Sondern der Adressat war das Thema. Und da gab es so bizarre, das muss man sich nochmal angucken, so bizarre Gegebenheiten, wo dann irgendein Grenz rankam. Und als erstes versprach er, jetzt wird mit der Bürokratie erstmal aufgeräumt hier. Also wir müssen uns irgendwie gegen die Bürokraten und wir brauchen mehr Beteiligung und mehr Demokratie.
Und der war doch ein Bürokrat oder?
Natürlich, der war aber ratschig schlechthin. Ich glaube niemanden...
Und Egon Grenz, daran erinnere ich mich wie heute, bei der ersten Interview, die er gab, als er aus der Volkskammer rauskam, sehr unklug von ihm, aber interessant, dass er das sagte, fragte ihn die Reporterin eine Frage vom Massenmedium Fernsehen. Herr Grenz, was wird jetzt kommen? Und darauf eher, wir müssen arbeiten, arbeiten, arbeiten. Das wäre ein völlig sinnloser... Er wollte damit wahrscheinlich sagen, wir im Politbüro oder so etwas. Aber es war ja so eine ausgepowerte Gesellschaft, die diesen Begriff Arbeit eben auch ganz anders sich übersetzt. Und das politische Semantik mit der Wirklichkeit total nichts mehr zu tun hat, sehe ich eben auch in diesem Leistungsbegriff. Mir kann eben kein CDU-Verantwortlicher jetzt mehr das für sich reklamieren, wenn dieses System jetzt nicht, wenn diese Euro-Krise jetzt nicht in der Weise gelöst wird, wie sie zu lösen ist, bedenken sie. Der Herr Gerke, dessen Vornamen ich nicht weiß, das ist ein Mensch, das ist ein Bankenprofessor, der taucht seit Jahren immer wieder auf. Also wenn einer sozusagen ein Anhänger auch von dem des herrschenden Systems eigentlich gewesen wäre, dann eher. Der sagte gestern den Satz, eins ist ganz klar, was wir im Augenblick mit Griechenland tun, ist, wir helfen nur den reichen Griechen. Wir helfen nur denen, die Geld haben. Der sagt, es ist natürlich auch das gleiche über die Banken, dass das so nicht geht und so weiter und so fort. Wir sind eigentlich schon auf hoher See. Wir haben das feste Land längst hinter uns gelassen. Wir sind jetzt auf hoher See und sie haben auch keinen Orientierungspunkt mehr. So kommt es mir halt vor. Ich kann das nur sagen. Wir bauen uns künstliche Leuchttürme. Die Medien machen das, indem sie künstliche Erwartungen wecken. Jetzt vor diesem EU-Gipfel und ähnliches. Das sind ja die künstlichen Erwartungen. Jetzt wird was passieren. Jetzt wird was passieren. Was macht jetzt Merkel? Aber in Wahrheit ist das alles nur so wie Leuchtpatronen. So kommt es mir vor, die man in die Luft schießt.
Es ist nicht nur schlecht. Ich gucke mit großer Genugtuung, wenn der Gysi jetzt im Bundestag eine Rede hält. Im Wesentlichen stellt er sich dahin und erzählt eine Stunde lang, habe ich euch doch gleich gesagt. Ich meine, er hat es ja auch wirklich schon seit vielen Jahren erzählt gelingen.
Das kann niemand beschreiten. Das kann niemand beschreiten.
Das Lustige ist ja, dass ich glaube, dass die Linken damit genauso überrascht werden wie die anderen, dass das System tatsächlich ins Platz geht.
Also ich war hier mal in Potsdam unterwegs. Das war in der Lehmann-Krise. In einem Spazierengang. Plötzlich kam mir ein älteres Ehepaar entgegen. Und dann sag ich zu meiner Frau, zu dem, bei dem ich dagegen sag, das sieht aus wie Egon Krenz. Und der kam dann hier tatsächlich, es war Egon Krenz. Und dann sagte ich zu ihm, sprach ihn an, und sagte ihm, na Herr Krenz, was sagen Sie denn dazu, dass jetzt zehn oder was war das, 20 Jahre nach dem Fall der Mauer, der Kapitalismus fällt? Und dann sagte er so ganz angelegentlich, glauben Sie das wirklich? Und dann sagte ich, na ja, so ein bisschen wird es ja so. Und er sagte, ach, 20 Jahre zu spät.
Hübsche Geschichte. Ja, aber die Frage ist ja dann doch, wenn wir uns so angucken, was unsere Politiker da so tun, wir haben ja festgestellt, eigentlich ist es mehr so hektisches Paddeln, und wirklich versuchen noch irgendwie dabei, so ein bisschen seriös auszusehen, was irgendwie so ein bisschen schwierig ist beim Ertrinken. Und die Frage ist ja am Ende, gibt es denn noch, oder bzw. gibt es denn neue Mechanismen, neue Wirkmöglichkeiten für politische Gestaltung, die sich jetzt entwickeln können? Also ist denn diese, was wir gerade sehen halt, die Sachen mit dem Internet, wo sie ja sehr skeptisch sind, ob es mit den Piraten irgendeiner Art von neuen Sachen sich entwickelt? Ich bin da ein bisschen...
Ich bin da gar nicht so skeptisch. Nee, gar nicht. Ich bin da gar nicht so skeptisch. Ich glaube nur, die mediale Realität ist eben... Gar nicht. Ich baue da sehr darauf. Ich glaube nur, der mediale Monster, sagen wir mal, ist ein Verdauungssystem. Unglaublich. Das kann sehr, sehr viel kaputt machen. Und das ist eher meine Skepsis. Ich bin skeptisch, ob Altmaier, ob es reicht. Ich merke im Internet, es reicht schon nur zu sagen, ich twittere und man ist schon beliebt. Also ob das jetzt alles noch... Das muss ich noch entwickeln. Aber ich bin da gar nicht skeptisch. Ich frage mich eher, und da bin ich bei dem, was auch Fefe vorhin sagte, ob wir wirklich realisiert haben, dass wir in einem System im Augenblick leben, wo niemand die Antwort weiß. Das glaube ich. Zum Beispiel der Journalismus ja auch nicht. Und das wäre doch eine Chance, wenn ich mal was Optimistisches sagen kann.
Die Verständigung über das Neue.
Ja, und dann eben auch für Ideale. Also jetzt wäre doch die Chance zu sagen, was Europa einem wert ist. Und zwar unabhängig von dieser aufgedrückten ökonomischen Frage. Jetzt wäre doch die Möglichkeit, solche Fragen zu stellen, was einem Freiheit wert ist, was einem das Grundgesetz wert ist, was einem eine Vereinigung Europäischer Stadt ist. Das wäre jetzt doch die allerbeste Chance, das zu machen. Und das ist ja auch das, was ich der Politik am meisten vorwerf. Wir sind in gewisser Weise von Ökonomie befreit, weil das System Ökonomie in gewisser Weise implodiert. Es kann kein Argument mehr sein. Weil ich kenne, sagen sie mir einen, der das versteht, was im Augenblick vor sich geht und darauf eine Antwort hat. Ich kenne niemanden.
Das finde ich einen sehr interessanten Gedanken, dass uns das befreit. Sollte ich das noch nicht gesehen? Ich habe allerdings neulich ein Kommentar von einem Schriftsteller, ich weiß leider nicht mehr, welche Zeitung es war, oder wer der Schriftsteller hieß. Aber der hat genau diese Fragen gestellt und das fand ich sehr spannend, dass dieses Gespür des Großen Ganzen eben doch noch eine Sache ist, die eher Schriftsteller und Historiker und Föjeton machen kann, als der Politikreporter, der zu sehr in den Details drin hängt und der die Gesamtbewegungen nicht erkennt, weil er die kleinen Strömungen sieht.
Zum Beispiel der Satz, der jetzt immer kommt, den müsste man gleich mal zensieren, also geistig. Wir haben vom Euro sehr profitiert. Schon der ist falsch. Selbst wenn wir nicht profitiert hätten in diesem klassischen ökonomischen Sinn, ist doch die Frage eine ganz andere. Nämlich, wie haben wir auf der Metaebene von ihm profitiert? Was bedeutet, was haben wir dadurch gewonnen, wenn wir an die Geschichten unserer Vorväter denken, das ist nicht nur Krieg, das ist ja viel, viel mehr. Das heißt, wir könnten ganz viel Ballast jetzt loswerden. Einer totalen, also des Primats des ökonomischen Diskurses, vor allem anderen, der hat uns alle, er hat auch mich. Ich bin auch davon infiziert gewesen in den 90er Jahren. Plötzlich schien es ja so, als sei da eine Theorie, es ist wie eine physikalische Gleichung, mit der es funktionieren könnte. Ich bin ja kein Ökonom. Und dann dachte man, ja, dann werden alle, ich weiß noch, wie ich in der Wildformel, wie in der großen Aktienblase 2000 Menschen auftauchten und sagten, das wird so irre sein, jeder Arbeitnehmer wird auch Aktienbesitzer seines Unternehmens sein, dann ein Interesse haben, dass es ihm gut geht usw. Das ist ja alles, der Start-up-Communismus. Und jetzt können wir uns befreien. Und ich will jetzt noch was zu den Piraten sagen. Ich habe die Grünen damals aus großer Nähe erlebt, das wirkliche, und da kann ich leider auch das nur noch mal unterstreichen, das wirkliche Phänomen, deren größten Stärke im Augenblick ist gar nicht, dass sie sich in digitalen Systemen auskennen oder so, sondern es ist wirklich, dass sie die Spiele nicht mitspielen, erkennen wir auch medial nicht mitspielen. Und wenn ihnen das, das ist mehr als Verweigerung, man hat manchmal den Eindruck, die verstehen die auch gar nicht. Insofern sollte man ihnen vielleicht die Staatstrojaner-Schweigsamkeit auch nachsehen. Wenn sie das, also das wäre wirklich so ein Virus im System, wer nicht mitspielt bei bestimmten Erwartungen einer rein medial organisierten Gesellschaft oder politisch organisierten Gesellschaft, der könnte echt einen großen Vorteil haben. Insofern bin ich da eigentlich voller spannender, spannender, gespannter Erwartung.
Ja, die Frage lautet ja dann, wie funktioniert denn die neuen Transportmechanismen? Vor allem die neuen Diskursmechanismen, weil das, um sozusagen mal den Bogen von unserem Anfangsthema wieder so ein bisschen zurückzuspannen, nämlich was wir festgestellt haben ist, der momentane politische Diskurs ist ja doch ziemlich kaputt. Also wir sehen auf der einen Seite Politiker, die halt nur noch in Echtzeit reagieren auf das, was irgendwie auf Spiegel Online steht oder auf bild.de steht. Auf der anderen Seite finden eigentlich tiefgreifende Debatten im Politikteil der Zeitung nicht mehr statt. So, sondern maximal halt noch irgendwie in den Vortrag schauen.
Das ist schon das Wichtigste.
Ja gut, also ich werde, ja, ok, gut.
Ausnahmen bestätigen.
Ja, gut. Aber ja, ok, also die Medien sind ja doch in einer situation, wo genau diese Debatten halt sich eigentlich nur noch sehr mühsam leisten können.
Leider, aber das ist das Aufregendste, was es doch gibt.
Ja, sollte man denken. Aber solange die Leute aber mit diesen Talkshows abgefüttert werden und fest denken, dass die Debatten da stattfinden, wo sie nie stattfinden, ist die Frage, wo, also wie sieht denn die neue Verständigung aus? Also wie, wenn wir jetzt sagen, ok, die Piraten nehmen wir mal an, die sind cleverer als wir denken. Und irgendwie, dass wir sie dafür gehänselt haben, dass sie in den medialen Debatten nicht vorkommen, ist vielleicht einfach auch nur eine schlaue Ignoranz, zu sagen, ok, wir müssen das nicht, uns reicht es, wenn wir irgendwie auf Internet und Facebook, also auf Twitter und Facebook im Internet präsent sind, weil wir da die Leute erreichen, die uns sowieso verstehen wollen. Und gut, wenn man sich Liquid Feedback zum Beispiel anguckt, interessant, was ich da gerade sehe, ich guck da mal wieder gerne mal rein. Liquid Feedback ist ja dieses Piraten-Tool, um sozusagen politischen Diskurs zu machen von den Nordost-Piraten, die Südwest-Piraten haben ja ein anderes. Aber was man da sieht, ist, dass die integration von neuen Mitgliedern funktioniert da offenbar tatsächlich. Also ist so, dass da eine Menge Leute reinkommen, die kriegen ihren Liquid Feedback-Account und die fangen da richtig an zu debattieren. Also es ist richtig, teilweise richtig erfrischend.
Das sehen Sie auch bei Altmaier, das ist ja ein Phänomen, das verfolge ich jetzt wirklich aus der Nähe. Ich habe ihn ja auch angerufen und gesagt, Sie müssen jetzt schreiben Sie bei uns, geben Sie Ihre Erklärung ab. Und das ist übrigens zur Rolle der Medien. Diese Leuchtturmcharakter oder diesen repräsentativen Charakter, das ist eine ganz große Chance für Medien. Wir dürfen nicht irgendwelchen diskussionen hinterherlaufen, sondern wir müssen sie auslösen. Und das ist durch Altmaier passiert. Darauf hat dann Pavel Maier geantwortet. Am Montag wird der Beck von den Grünen. Das sind jetzt im Augenblick noch so Erklärungen, wie so weiter, ich bin dabei. Aber es zeigt, dass da eine Vernetzung stattfinden kann. Auch auf der Medienwirklichkeit, das merken wir immer wieder, ist eine noch einmal, ich will gar nicht sagen, realitätsgesättigtere, aber eine verbindlichere als die andere. Im Augenblick jedenfalls noch. Wenn beides zusammentrifft, passiert sowas wie im Fall Altmaier, von dem ich glaube im Augenblick, dass man fast beobachten kann, dass der Gerät in so eine Euphorie rein. Das ist fast, ich will jetzt nicht sagen unter Drogen, aber der ist richtig, das wird ein völlig anderer Mensch durch Twitter.
Das ist, geht allen Leuten auf Twitter so, wenn die sehen, dass sie, bei Twitter hat man den unmittelbaren Feedback, nicht nur, dass die Leute antworten, sondern man sieht auch, wie viele sich ein Follower eingetragen haben. Das heißt, man sieht, wie viele Leute interessiert, was ich sage. Und wenn das über Nacht hochgeht, auf vier- oder fünfstellig, und das ist das, was er erlebt hat. Genau, und das kann die Persönlichkeit ändern. Was mich immer untreibt, ist, wenn die Leute sich eine Talkshow angucken und danach nicht mehr die Debatte in der FAZ lesen, weil sie glauben, sie haben die Antworten schon gekriegt, oder noch schlimmer gar, es gibt keine Antworten, weil in der Talkshow gab es keine. Was können wir dann da tun? Und wenn ich darüber nachdenke, frage ich mich, wenn jetzt so ein Glücksgriff kommt, wie dieses Friedrich-Interview in der FAZ, wo er sich ja um Kopf und Kragen geredet hat, hätte die FAZ da nicht noch mehr Punkte machen können, wenn sie gleich den Kommentar hintergehauen hätte?
Nee, das darf man nicht machen. Das heißt, das Denken der Menschen abschneiden. Wir brauchen immer einen Echo-Rahmen, wir brauchen einen inkubationsraum. Das heißt, das steht jetzt in der Gesellschaft und jetzt sollen sich alle mal darüber Gedanken machen. Gleich ein Kommentar dazu ist, finde ich, total verwerflich.
Ich auch, aber ich finde, wir müssen, das ist unser Bildungsauftrag, dass wir das hier erklären.
Aber jetzt, das kommt ja am nächsten Tag oder am übernächsten, man...
Nein, ich meine, wir müssen hier erklären, warum da kein Kommentar drunter ist.
Ach so, der Kommentar ist nicht drunter, weil das, was das größte, was wir leisten können, ist, reflexionen in Gang zu setzen. Jetzt liest das jemand, in dieser inkubation passiert das und dann, das haben wir ja auch gemacht, ich habe ja dann ein paar Tage später einen Kommentar dazu geschrieben, aber bewusst nicht gleich. Nehmen Sie die Talkshows, auch ein interessanter Fall. Die meistgeklickten Artikel bei uns und bei den anderen sind die morgendlichen Besprechungen der Talkshows, die die Menschen ja schon gesehen haben. Das heißt, was die dann wollen, ist die Einordnung.
Das ist ja hart.
Genau, ist die Einordnung und dieses Prinzip ist etwas, ich sehe das auch bei, ich meine, ich habe noch nie so viel mit Altmaier zu tun gehabt, seitdem er twittert.
Warum?
Weil er auch diese Einordnung, dann sozusagen Rückmeldungen und dergleichen, wartet sicherlich jetzt, dass irgendwann mal ein Artikel kommt, der das auch beschreibt und so. Das alles ist, ich sehe das alles als eine Form von kooperation, überhaupt nicht von... nur, und das ist jetzt meine Frage, weil sie beide da ja viel, viel, das viel besser kennen und viel tiefer drin sind als ich. Wir reden immer noch von einer Avantgarde, also wir reden immer noch von einer situation, das kennen wir alle, First Mover, Advantage und so weiter. Was, jetzt kommt, jetzt erklärt der Altmaier, ich habe heute schon gesehen, cdu-bundestagsfraktion twittert jetzt auch massiv, ist schon, aber wird immer stärker. Was passiert eigentlich, wenn jetzt tatsächlich, massiv, also nehmen Sie jetzt nur die jugendorganisationen der Parteien, alles Individuen, wenn das sich verwässert, also wenn jetzt das tatsächlich auch wieder zu einem, diese, die First Movers sind ja meistens auch sehr bewusste Menschen, wenn jetzt also tatsächlich das zu einem Interessen fällt, wird nicht nur Twitter, aber auch vieles andere, was wird dann sein?
Wenn man also, jetzt ist nicht mehr nur Altmaier, wenn die Leute nicht interessant sind, folgt ihnen halt niemand.
Genau, es findet sehr schnell so eine, das ist ja auch gesellschaftlich so.
Diese lektion ist halt brutal schnell, also gerade auf Twitter oder auch auf den anderen Sachen, also eben oder bei Blogs zum Beispiel. Das ist halt also, wenn in dem Augenblick, ist das wirklich interessant? Wenn man nicht interessant ist, also wenn es halt nicht so, bei Altmaier ist es so, das ist nicht, was er twittert gerade interessant, sondern, dass er macht hat. Sondern, dass er twittert. Das ist gerade der Punkt, der interessant ist, in dem Augenblick, wo es halt nicht mehr interessant ist, also wo halt zu sagen, nicht mehr der Fakt, dass er jetzt twittert, also dass er in der digitalen Wirk- schaft Wirklichkeit angekommen ist, sondern, wenn es darum geht...
Er muss jetzt nachlegen, sonst ist er in zwei Tagen wieder weg.
Was passiert dann? Ist er vielleicht in zwei Wochen oder so, ist tatsächlich wieder weg. Man ist ja auch der Grund, warum Feifers Blog funktioniert, ist weil es halt konstant interessant ist. Also weil es halt nie einen, es gibt halt kein Nachlassen dabei. Und das ist halt eine...
Ist das wirklich so? Ist das, ist interessant die Kategorie? Das wäre ja wirklich interessant.
Das ist auch die Chance der Medien. Warum sind denn die ganzen Zeitungen in dem Augenblick, wo sie sich entscheiden, dass sie noch DPA-Print machen?
Genau, Geklonte.
Also bisher, wenn man dir die Auflagen anguckt, die dümpeln halt alle so nach unten. In dem Augenblick, wo so ein Provinzblatt zum Beispiel sagt, wir gedrucken jetzt DPA, sind die ganz schnell weg. Wir kicken unsere lokalredaktion, dann sind die ein Jahr später zu. Das ist ganz klar. Also worum geht es halt immer, die Story? Also wer keine Geschichte zu erzählen hat, ist halt weg.
Also es stimmt nicht die These, dass wenn jetzt sozusagen die Massen dort einwandern, das wäre nämlich meine These gewesen, wir es genau wie in allen anderen Systemen zu dem Gesetz sozusagen der durchschnittlichen Mitte kommen und das ganze System halt einfach nur ein kommunikationssystem unter vielen ist mit ein paar Highlights.
Natürlich wird es weiter verbessern.
Naja, das ist mehr als es klingt, denn es bildet sich ja so eine Gruppendynamik wie auch in anderen sozialen Systemen. Also es gibt in der Firma, in der Raucherpause, wenn getrautscht wird, dann gibt es auch so Multiplikatoren, die immer in der Mitte stehen und der Rest ist eigentlich nur dabei, um mitzukriegen, was passiert. Und so ist es auf Twitter auch. Da gibt es eben so ein paar Knoten in der Mitte von dem Grafen, mit denen viele, wo sich viele angehängt haben, aber die sind eben die wichtigen. Und deswegen ist Twitter im Moment für die großen Parteien so wichtig, weil jetzt die Leute, die jetzt als erste reingehen, die besetzen das Feld für ihre Partei.
Und was muss Altmaier denn jetzt liefern? Denn er kann ja nicht das liefern, was man von ihm erwartet.
Spannende Inhalte.
Eben, er kann ja nicht erzählen, er kann ja keine Geheimnisse verraten.
Na ja, er könnte ja so tun, als täte er es. Das meinen die meisten ja auch nicht.
Also das ist tatsächlich so, wenn es halt nur Parteitransport ist und irgendwie ein bisschen gejubelt und ein bisschen gekuschelt mit den anderen.
Da ist er ganz schnell weg.
Dann wird das nicht. Was er jetzt an seiner Stelle tun würde, wir können es ja mal vorher sagen, damit es was wieder mal tut. Er würde wahrscheinlich jetzt so lange mit den Piraten kuscheln, bis alle Leute darüber reden, ob es da nicht eine schwarz-orange koalition geben wird.
Ja, das tut er ja.
Das ist ja ein bisschen offensiver.
Nicht nur kuscheln. Es gibt ja viele, ich sage mal jetzt so was wie ein Redenprotokoll oder so, was nicht so aufgefallen ist, aber was eigentlich eine Sache für die Piraten wäre. Und da haben die einfach im Moment nicht die Infrastruktur, um das von selbst zu entdecken. Und wenn der Altmaier einfach in seinem Twitter dann auf so was hinweist, auch gar nicht mal guckt mal Piraten, sondern einfach nur guckt mal, was ich gefunden habe und seine Follower sehen dann, da gibt es ab und zu was Interessantes. Das reicht ja völlig. Wir erwarten ja gar nicht von unseren Quellen, dass sie die gesamte Arbeit machen. Und was bringt der dann der CDU? Der CDU bringt ja, dass sie im Gespräch bleibt.
Modernität.
Aber genau, aber Moment, bisher ist ja noch gar nicht viel passieren. Wir reden jetzt von einem Menschen, der twittert. Wir haben einen Artikel gedruckt. Ich kenne ihn ja. Also er twittert, er öffnet sich ein bisschen. Aber das ist genau das, was er übrigens auch mit Journalisten täte. Im Grunde hat sich jetzt verlagert das Hintergrundgespräch mit Journalisten in Twitter.
Naja, aber es schrieb ja auch durchaus, dass er mehr Demokratie wagen will. Und am Ende ist es ja genau das, worüber wir gerade geredet haben. Nämlich den den Versuch zu unternehmen, uns gesellschaftlich darüber zu verständigen, was jetzt eigentlich notwendig ist. So in dem Augenblick, wo halt klar wird, dass das, was er da tut, eh nur transmissionsriemen für seine Partei ist, ist es uninteressant.
Das wird eben der interessante Moment sein.
Dann wird es halt langweilig. In dem Augenblick, wo wir aber davon reden, dass wir im Internet digitale runde Tische bilden und uns einfach mal als Gesellschaft üben. Über die Parteigrenzen hinweg darüber unterhalten, wie es jetzt eigentlich weitergehen soll, wo wir eigentlich hinwollen, was die Ideale sind, nachdem wir eine Gesellschaft bauen wollen. Dann wird es spannend. Das ist das eigentliche Wichtigste.
Das Stichwort ist übrigens Rundetische.
So digitale Rundetische ist eigentlich das, was ich mir da wünsche, was da passiert und wo die Piraten auch eine Menge beitragen können, dass wir halt einfach uns hinsetzen und sagen, okay, wir sind in dieser situation, wir müssen natürlich darüber reden, wie wir dahingekommen sind, aber am Ende ist diese, diese Finanzkatastrophe, hat sie eben tatsächlich die Ausmaße einer Naturkatastrophe. Das heißt, wir müssen uns jetzt auch einfach darüber unterhalten, wie geht es denn jetzt eigentlich weiter und was wir daraus lernen. So und das nicht mehr so weiter geht wie vorher, ist allen klar. Aber der Verständigungsmechanismus darüber, wie es jetzt weitergehen soll, ist der einzige, den ich sehe, ist eben tatsächlich eine Digitalisierung der Demokratie.
Ich glaube ja nicht, dass es weitergehen kann, bevor wir überhaupt analysiert haben, was da genau passiert ist. Das durchblickt doch keiner. Im Moment ist doch alles, was wir sagen, ach die scheiß Banker, die haben uns über den Tisch gezogen. Aber das ist doch mehr ein System als die Leute. Die Leute haben doch nur ihre Rolle erfüllt. Die ist zwar widerlich und abartig und ich kann die Leute alle verachten, aber was ich verhindern muss, ist das System. Ich kann auch nicht nur sagen, die Leute sind böse.
Kann ich nur ein Beispiel erzählen, ohne dass das egoman oder sowas ist. Aber das kann ich ruhig öffentlich mal. Gar nicht, es geht gar nicht, dass ich da beleidigt bin oder so. Ich habe mich da mit der Demografie befasst, 2004. Da war die Merkel noch oppositionsführerin. Ich bin ja überzeugt, dass das eine ganz schlimme Sache ist. Und dass es eigentlich ein Betrug ist. Und dass wir ihn dann spüren, wenn wir uns nicht mehr wehren können. Das ist meine ausgangsposition. Wenn ich 30 bin, kann ich mich wehren. Wenn es mich erwischt, wenn ich plötzlich mit 60 sehe oder mit 65, ist das alles nicht mehr da, ist es schlimmer. Da sagte Angela Merkel damals, es war sogar öffentlich, die wollte das Buch unbedingt, die wollte das Thema unbedingt vorstellen. Und es ging darum, wie können wir die Gesellschaft aufklären, was kann man eigentlich machen, ohne dass man den ganzen Banken und Lebensversicherungen hier einen Markt eröffnet, dass das klar wird, dass hier ein echtes Problem entsteht. Da sagte sie, das mache ich zum Thema meiner Kanzlerschaft. Und das ist das, was, wenn ich das war, das ist wirklich so wichtig und so weiter. Und zwar vor dieser Veranstaltung von vielen, vielen Menschen. Und da habe ich mal aus der Nähe erlebt, wie so etwas dann passiert. Die hat das, also ich kann nicht behaupten, sie kennt das Problem nicht, das hat sie total verstanden. Sie weiß, ich weiß, dass sie im Kabinettstischen darüber geredet wird, dass sie, einer sagte mir das mal, ich sagte, als ich einfach sagte, sagen Sie, sehen Sie das? Ich sagte, ja, wir wollen ja auch nicht alle später in 10-Bett-Zimmern gefesselt sitzen als alte Menschen, weil es nicht genug Pfleger gibt und so. Also das Problem, was da alles auf uns zukommt, ist klar. Und haben Sie irgendwo ein Indiz, außer dass Frau von der Leyen Pflegejahre einfällt, dass diese, das ist ja so ein Punkt, dass so, das sind ja nicht Nebenthemen der Gesellschaft, das sind Themen, die uns so zentral, die auch zum Umbau der Gesellschaft führen müssten, wo man so sagen würde, dass wir müssen alles dafür tun, dass junge Menschen integriert werden. Das hat ja alles damit zu tun. Ich sehe das eben gar nicht. Und darum glaube ich, dass diese Twitter-Demokratie, die da digitale Demokratie da entstehen könnte, im Augenblick mehr eine Art von simulation ist, weil die Leute im Augenblick auch relativ leicht befriedigt sind. Man muss nur die richtigen Worte sagen. Die Handlungen, die Taten werden nicht abgefragt. Also sie sagen ja, wenn der Altmaier nicht die Taten bringt, dann ist er schnell wieder weg. Aber wer hat...
Das ist aber unsere Aufgabe.
Wer ist denn dafür bisher bestraft worden? Es ging immer nur um Worte.
Das ist vielleicht auch bei meiner Forderung nach. Na gut.
Nein, aber das ist letztlich die Aufgabe von Bloggern und von den Medien, die Leute daran zu erinnern, was sie vor ein paar Jahren gesagt haben und dass sie nichts getan haben. Die Twitter und Blogs und das Internet ist ein großartiges Medium, um Empörung hervorzurufen, wenn man die Fakten auf den Tisch legt. Und wenn der Altmaier das tut, dann wird er Leute haben, die sein Kram lesen. Und wenn er es nicht tut, wird er die nicht haben. Aus meinen Augen ist das so einfach. Und im Moment ist das so, dass der größte Nutzen, der jetzt konkret aus dem Internet und der Vernetzung entsteht, ist, dass Leute einfach Dinge wie diese gefälschten, eigentlich gefälschten, verbesserten Protokolle beim Bundestag, die fallen einfach auf. Irgendeinem fallen die auf, wenn es genügend Aufmerksamkeit gibt für so ein Thema, dann fällt sowas eben auf. Und die Aufgabe von den Medien, und ich nehme mich da ein, ich bin auch Teil davon, ist, dass ich eben gucke, welche Aspekte sind wichtig, und dann versuche ich, eben Aufmerksamkeit hinzuspielen und höre mir dann aber auch an, was die Leute herausfinden und versuche, so ein bisschen die Aufmerksamkeit zu lenken. Aber zu erwarten, dass ich da einfach einen Krumm hinwerfe und es klärt sich dann von selbst, das geschieht nicht.
Und wie sehen Sie die Chance, was ich mir von den Piraten so erhoffen würde, oder wünschen würde, diese Riesenmarktlöcke, die Chance, dass, ich rede ja nicht von der technologiefeindlichen Partei, sondern einer technologiekritischen, dass also die Expertise, die Sie beide ja haben, also aus der Informatik kommend, aus die Systeme kennend, dass ebenso eine Partei, auch eine Gesellschaft, wir können ja nicht dauernd sagen, das Digitale ist nur gut, sondern es ist ja erkennbar, es muss ja, was da alles drinsteckt. Der Trojaner ist jetzt auf der Staatsebene das Thema, aber im Grunde müsste doch jetzt eine Partei auch schon thematisieren, dass sie nicht zulassen wird, das Digitale System über Menschen zu urteilen, in der Weise, wie sie es vielleicht in der Zukunft tun werden. Dass nicht Arbeitsplätze nur das Finanzmärkte, nicht so. Das wäre ja eine richtige Expertenfrage auch. Also müssten Informatiker viel stärker in solchen Parteien eine Rolle spielen und so eine Partei müsste auch sich zum Anwalt von Menschen machen, die sagen, die Technologie hat eindeutig Grenzen. Und nicht nur bei den Staatstrojanern, sondern eben auch in der Arbeitswelt.
Das hat eben die Frage der Verständigung darüber, was wir halt tun wollen als Gesellschaft. Also welche Wege wir gehen wollen. Und dazu gehört natürlich eben auch, was wir halt mit Technologie beginnen wollen. Also welche Möglichkeiten in Technologie steckt und welche Probleme entstehen und was wir halt irgendwie, ja, also wie wir sie verwenden wollen. Und natürlich diese diskussion halt irgendwie mit der Spakaria zum Beispiel darüber, welchen Stellenwert halt irgendwie Privatsphäre haben soll oder welche Rechte wir halt zum Beispiel Konzernen geben wollen und irgendwie mit unseren Daten über unser Leben zu verfügen. Also da sehe ich schon durchaus ein ganz großes Feld von Verständigung, was halt irgendwie zwingend notwendig ist.
Naja, also es gibt halt ein inhärentes Problem, nämlich dass Informatiker und Techniker insgesamt von ihrer Herangehensweise lernen. Wir arbeiten mit unperfekten Komponenten, da kann immer mal was ausfallen, aber wir konstruieren daraus was Gutes. Diese Einsicht, dass Sachen inhärent nicht lösbar sind, ist ein großes Problem für viele Informatiker. Die meisten werden es in ihrer gesamten Karriere nie einsehen. Das ist einfach ein Sprung, den man von der Technikpartei, fürchte ich, weniger erwarten kann als von der anderen Partei. Man braucht halt ein paar Techniker, also es gibt natürlich kritische Informatiker und es gibt auch den CCC natürlich. Wir machen ja auch so was wie Folgenabschätzung, aber das Studium bereitet einen genau aus der anderen Richtung, darauf vor auf das Leben und sagt, wir können das alles managen, wir müssen nur lernen wie.
Der Ingenieursansatz.
Das ist der Ingenieursansatz, genau. Und diese Leute dazu zu bringen, dass sie dann sagen, ja, aber das hat also auch negative Folgen und das müssen wir verhindern, das ist ein ganz großer Schritt und deswegen sieht man den auch so selten von Technikern gegangen. Leider. Aber solange denen dann jemand zuhört, den paar, die den Schritt gehen, finde ich das nicht so schlimm. Und man das jetzt von den Piraten erwarten kann, ich hoffe ja, wenn wir sehen.
Wenn wir das mal so ein bisschen zusammenfassen, wir stellen fest, unser politischer Diskurs hat sich dann doch ziemlich verändert und wir sind gerade in der Phase, wo sich neue Diskursformen herausbilden, hoffen wir.
Und neue Strukturen gesellschaftlich sind, auch nicht nur der Diskurs, der sich ändert.
Na ja, ich meine, wir brauchen ja halt eine gesellschaftliche Verständigung darüber, wie es halt weitergehen soll, was jetzt danach kommt.
Ich finde es auffallend, dass, wenn wir darüber reden, wir bei zwei Punkten ankommen, nämlich erstens den runden Tisch vom Ende der DDR und zweitens mehr Demokratiewagen von Willy Brandt. Das sind doch so die beiden Fixpunkte, die haben wir am Anfang gehabt und die haben wir jetzt wieder.
Dass wir in runden Tischen ist, das ist in meinen Augen der runde Tisch war ja, ist ja dann abgeschafft worden. Also wir sind ja...
Ja, der wollte zum Beispiel eine neue Verfassung für Gesamtverschaffung haben.
Ich weiß, ich weiß. Der runde Tisch ist auch ein Krisensymptom. Ich erinnere mich genau an die runde Tisch, aber wir sind, wenn wir das schon mal anerkennen, dass wir in dieser Phase sind, das fällt mir da ein bisschen wie Schuppen vor den Augen. Dann sind wir schon im Jahr zwei nach der Krise. Also Jahr eins implosion, Jahr zwei wäre schon der runde Tisch.
Na gut, die runden Tische sind ja erst dann sozusagen anerkannt, wenn es sie gibt. Also worüber wir gerade reden ist von der Notwendigkeit der runden Tisch.
Altmaier und Beck und Schlauer, das sind schon runde Tische.
Die kommen schon in die richtige Richtung.
Aber ich will nur sagen, ich habe noch was Drittes. Ich komme ja nochmal aus dieser anderen Ecke. Die Kategorie des Interessanten. Das ist für mich eines der Highlights dieser Gespräche. Wenn er nichts Interessantes liefert, ist er schnell weg oder wenn ein Blog nicht interessant ist. Interessant ist eine ästhetische Kategorie. Es ist eine Kategorie der Kunst. Das Interesse ist etwas, was definiert ästhetische Diskurse. Und das ist auch in der Zeitung so. Ich will eine interessante Diskurse. Das ist auch in meinen Augen die Zukunft der Zeitung. Nicht vorgegebene, nicht geklonte Diskurse. Interessante Diskurse, das Interesse als Kategorie. Das heißt, ich will nicht gelangweilt sein. Das reicht schon, als ist schon eine politische Aussage. Und wenn wir die ernst nehmen, hieße es, wir schalten die Talkshows alle ab. Wir schalten die Bundestagsreden voll. Sie müssen uns was bieten. Und zwar nicht Unterhaltung im Sinne vom Thriller unbedingt. Das wäre auch nicht schlecht, aber Interesse. Interessant, denn Interessant, so ist es definiert, heißt auch, du interessierst dich für dein Gegenüber. Nur dann kannst du nämlich interessant sein.
In beide Richtungen.
Ganz genau.
Wenn ich nämlich nicht das Gefühl habe, dass die mich ernst nehmen, dann höre ich noch nicht zu.
Und das ist eine Sache, die unsere Politiker alle noch lernen müssen. Und wo die Piratenpartei möglicherweise einen Vorsprung hat durch diesen direkten Twitter-Vorsprung.
Ja, und wo das digitale System eine Unglade, das ist, muss ich jetzt wirklich sagen, ist eine Erkenntnis hier unseres Gesprächs. In einer vordigitalen Welt können sie in Medien machen, was sie wollen und ob da einer zuguckt oder nicht. Die können ja nicht anders. In einer digitalen Welt ist der Darwinismus. Der Darwinismus heißt, das ist ein Darwinistisches Prinzip, ich überlebe nur durch Interesse. Jetzt entscheiden sich manche für Boulevard oder für Sex oder das was auch immer. Aber in unserem politischen Diskurs hieße das eben was ganz anderes. Und das wäre dann echt, also das wäre ein Wettbewerb, der könnte echt total tolle Ergebnisse haben.
Ja, kann auch voll nach hinten losgehen, wenn die Leute Big Brother gucken würden.
Ja gut, das geht immer.
Hauptsache wir bleiben interessant mit Alternativlos.
Genau, dann bedanken wir uns nochmal ganz herzlich für das Gespräch.
Danke sehr.
Das war doch eine sehr interessante Sendung.
Das glaube ich auch relativ lang.
Wir sind jetzt bei 2.11, ja geht. Ja, also das war Alternativlos Nr. 20. Wenn ihr uns ein bisschen Geld zukommen wollt, da rechts ist der Flitterbutton für diese Sendung. Und ansonsten bedanken wir uns fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.